Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Ich bin ein ganz guter Mensch. Ich bin ein ganz guter Mensch. Ich bin ein ganz guter Mensch.
Wenn das Getränk nicht da war, ein neuer Bundespräsident ist gewählt worden und der Bundesinnenminister hat es für eine gute Idee 14 Thesen dazu zu schreiben, was man mit der Netzpolitik so machen soll. Und das ist das Thema, worum es heute gehen soll. Hier im Chaosradio, zu dem ich euch recht herzlich willkommen heiße, am 30. Juni, also im letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Ihr seid herzlich eingeladen mitzumachen bei allem worum es hier geht, was wir gleich nochmal genau erklären werden. Das könnt ihr vielfältige Weise tun. Am liebsten ist uns natürlich nach wie vor, wenn ihr diese eine Telefonnummer genutzt, die wir zur Verfügung haben. 0331 70 97 110 Oder ihr könnt auch im Wiki euren Kommentar hinterlassen, oder im Blog, oder im IRC-Kanal mit uns chatten. Das gibt es alles im Wiki unter chaosradio.de zu klicken, wo man das wie machen kann. Ich kann nur eins gleich sagen. Einer der Gäste wird heute nicht unterwegs sein und das ist Fefe. Guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Warum wirst du nicht im IRC-Kanal sein?
Ich bin nie im IRC und wenn dann nicht unter meinem Namen. Das könnte ich nie zugeben, oder?
Außerdem zu Gast heute noch Daniel Schmidt. Warum bist du nicht im IRC? Ihr beide seid heute im Radio, weil wir über ein Thema sprechen wollen. Der Anlass zumindest war 14 Thesen zu den Grundlagen einer gemeinsamen Netzpolitik der Zukunft.
Genau.
Das hat ja der Herr de Maizière, unser Bundesinnenminister, zu Protokoll gegeben, war letzte Woche, glaube ich. Und ihr habt dann mal beschlossen, wir müssten das jetzt mal in richtig machen. Hab ich es richtig verstanden?
Ja, also, ich meine, die Hauptaufgabe des CCC ist ja in letzter Zeit gewesen, wenn die Politik mal wieder grob Mist macht irgendwo, dass wir das kommentieren und kritisieren und dann auch sagen, was man besser macht. Und dieses Mal haben wir das natürlich auch versucht, haben uns hingesetzt, haben gesagt, okay, wir lesen diese Thesen jetzt mal durch und wir haben die gelesen und hätten danach nicht sagen können, was da eigentlich drin stand. Das ist immer doof, wenn man eine Sache kritisieren soll, die eigentlich keine Aussage beinhaltet. Wir haben die sogar ausgedruckt. Wir sind ja eigentlich keine Internet-Ausdrucker, aber wir haben mal eine Ausnahme gemacht. Wir haben gedacht, hey, vielleicht funktioniert es besser, wenn man sie ausdruckt.
Guck mal, es ist doch ein Theseeinsatz, das hört sich doch gleich richtig gut an. Bewusstsein für gemeinsame Werte schaffen.
Schärfen.
Siehst du, so ist das. Die sind so schlüpfrig, diese Aussagen. Die kannst du nicht mal ablesen, da ist halt nichts dahinter.
Also ich vermute, wenn ich dich jetzt frage, was ist deine Lieblingsthese, die du einfach so übernehmen würdest, würdest du sagen?
Keine.
Keine, okay.
Also man muss es auch mal würdigen. Das ist ja eine Kunstform für Politiker, dass sie vier Seiten füllen können, ohne irgendwas zu sagen. Das ist ja eigentlich deren Kernkompetenz. Wir merken ja immer, dass sie keine Ahnung haben, aber eigentlich ist das ja eine Leistung.
Und das ja, nachdem extrem viele Netzdialoge ja vorher geführt wurden. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass er sich ganz alleine etwas hätte überlegen müssen für diese Thesen, sondern er hat ja auch aus der Community und von vielen anderen da sehr viel Feedback bekommen, was den Themen sind, die aufgegriffen werden müssten. Und viele von denen sind überhaupt nicht erst eingeflossen. Also das ist dann vielleicht die zweite Kunstform, wie man das, was einem von Experten nahegelegt wird, irgendwie möglichst gut ignoriert und dann hinterher etwas produziert, was immer nur noch heiße Luft ist.
Also hier, ich will mal eine zitieren, die das besonders schön macht. Hier steht zum Beispiel These 2. Rechtsordnung mit Augenmaß weiterentwickeln. Das heißt doch überhaupt nichts.
Wir sollten soweit als möglich auf das bestehende Recht zurückgreifen und Selbstregulierungskräfte stärken. Heißt auch, das Netz soll machen, was es will und wir erlassen keine neuen Gesetze, sondern...
Nee, nee, liess mal den letzten Satz. Die Entwicklung von nationalem, supranationalem und internationalem Recht muss Hand in Hand gehen. Also ja, er will die Gesetze doch weiterentwickeln. Er sagt erst nein, eigentlich reicht, was wir haben. Dann sagt er weiterentwickeln. Und damit es nicht irgendwie so ausgelegt wird, als, ach, die machen jetzt doofe Gesetze, schreibt er in die Überschrift, mit Augenmaß weiterentwickeln. Also das alles ist eine Übung darin, nichts zu sagen. Also da kann jetzt jeder genau das reinlesen, was er haben wollte, aber wenn du dich anstrengst, kannst du auch das Gegenteil dessen, was du haben wolltest, reinlesen.
Na warte mal, hier ein eindeutiger Satz. Ich habe einen eindeutigen Satz gefunden. Eine schrankenlose Anonymität kann es jedoch im Internet nicht geben.
Genau, das ist die Kehrseite von den Sachen. Die Stellen, wo er dann doch mal was sagt, die sind falsch.
Aber warum? Was ist denn dagegen einzuwenden?
Gegen Anonymität?
Nein, also wir sind eher im Gegenteil der Meinung als CCC, dass Anonymität eine wichtige Sache ist. Denn wenn ich mich zum Beispiel über irgendwelche Randgruppen Sexfetische informieren möchte, dann ist es vielleicht gut, wenn ich das machen kann, ohne zu offenbaren, dass ich es bin. Oder wenn ich mich informieren will über die Prävention von Sexualkrankheiten, die irgendwie besonders peinliche Auswirkungen haben, die mir peinlich werden. Oder wenn ich mich informieren will, ich bin in irgendeiner großen Firma und möchte mich informieren, wie das mit dem Job angebotene Konkurrenz ist, dann ist es natürlich wichtig.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, Regel 34 gilt ja sozusagen im Internet. Wenn ich weiß, was es ist, schlägt das jetzt nach. Ob das noch was gibt, was nicht mit Sex zu tun hat, warum man anonym sein will.
Genau, das habe ich ja gerade gesagt.
Es geht doch auch um politische Willensbildung und diese ganzen Geschichten. Ich muss doch das sagen können, was ich möchte, genau wie ich das auf der Straße sagen kann, ohne dass irgendjemand direkt von mir den Ausweis verlangt. Und ich mich ausweisen muss und mich dazu bekennen muss, dass ich als Person diese Aussage getroffen habe. So, das muss doch möglich sein. Es geht ja hier nicht unbedingt um illegale Dinge, sondern einfach darum, dass ich meine Meinung gut tun kann, ohne dass das irgendjemand überprüfen kann. Oder dass ich fürchten muss, dass irgendjemand kommt und das Recht hat, das zu überprüfen. Oder zu dokumentieren, irgendwo weiterzugeben.
Das ist nach wie vor wichtig, sage ich mal. Was ich hier noch schön fand, da möchte ich gerne noch eure Meinung dazu haben. Ähm, These 14. Staatliche IT-Systeme attraktiv und sicher ausgestalten. Wie weit sind wir davon entfernt? Oder haben wir es schon erreicht?
Ja, wie viele attraktive IT-Systeme? Also ich will gar nicht von der Sicherheit reden, aber wie viele attraktive?
Nee, davon würde ich aber lieber reden wollen.
Warte mal, das scheint doch schon eine Attraktivität. Hast du mal versucht, die Steuererklärung online zu machen zum Beispiel? Da kriegst du doch Ausschlag beim Versuch. Das geht doch gar nicht.
Das stimmt nicht. Ich habe nämlich Geld für ein Steuerberatungsprogramm ausgegeben, was mir das wiederum abnimmt.
Eben, eben! Weil es nämlich so scheiße ist, dass du lieber eine Software kaufst, um es für dich zu tun.
Okay, ja das stimmt.
Also wir kommen schon nicht mal mit der Attraktivität, was das einfache Kriterium ist, hin. Mit der Sicherheit müssen wir gar nicht anfangen.
Wieso nicht?
Na, weil das kein Mensch offen überprüfen kann. Das ist ja nicht so, dass sie den Quellcode veröffentlichen. Ich kann den halt glauben oder auch nicht.
Das heißt, eine abgeleitete Forderung wäre, also die Sicherheit von einem T-System ist schon eine gute Idee. Na, aber natürlich. Aber um das zu überprüfen, das sollte auch die Öffentlichkeit tun können. Und deswegen müsste das alles open source sein.
Im Idealfall sollte es jeder tun können, der qualifiziert dafür ist oder der Meinung ist, er möchte das tun. Das ist ja genau wie mit allem anderen der Punkt. Da sind wir dann auch gleich wieder beim Thema Transparenz und bei dem, wie nachprüfbar überhaupt alles sein sollte. Und das ist ganz natürlich was, was sehr wichtig ist. Das wird auch immer wichtiger, je komplexer die Welt wird. Und das ist genau einer der Punkte, die hier komplett fehlen in dieser ganzen Angelegenheit.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Genau, das ist übrigens eine alte Forderung vom CCC, der Maschinenlesbare Start. Was?
Warum das?
Na, wir haben Maschinenlesbare Ausweise, die brauchen wir eigentlich nicht. Wir möchten gerne einen Start haben, den ich mit meinem Computer bearbeiten kann, wo ich nicht alles selbst lesen muss, sondern wo mein Computer die Daten lesen kann.
Moment mal, aber seid ihr nicht auch die Leute, die immer sagen, ja irgendwie diese ganzen Datenbanken und so, das müsste man jetzt aber nicht öffentlich machen?
Ja, das stimmt ja auch. Also wir haben einen alten Spruch in der Hackerethik dazu, der heißt nämlich, dass du öffentliche Daten nützen sollst und private Daten schützt. Aber die Daten, die du hast, die sollen bitte maschinenlesbar sein. Der Start soll nicht deswegen vor Hackern sicher sein, weil er die Interfaces nicht anbietet, sondern die Daten, die wir haben, sollen bitte auch für alle verfügbar sein. Und zwar so, dass es auch jeder machen kann.
Okay, jetzt sind wir schon von den durchgehenden 14 Thesen zu dem, dass ihr ja eigene Thesen aufgestellt habt. Wobei ich noch einen interessanten Punkt finde. Warum eigentlich nicht vorher? Also ist man als Chaos-Club dazu, verdammt zu reagieren?
Gab es vorher? Vielleicht nicht vom CCC?
Das ist ja das, was ich meine. Das Ding ist, zum Beispiel jetzt, wie wir hier sitzen. Wir sitzen ja nicht hier an einem Mittwoch und sagen, wir stellen jetzt mal 25 Thesen oder wieviel auch immer ihr haben wollt zum Dienst auf. Sondern ihr sagt, so jetzt hat der Innenminister das gemacht, jetzt machen wir das auch.
Moment, das ist ja der Auffänger.
Da sind wir wieder an dem Punkt, dass der Innenminister vorher ja sogar, man konnte ja Fragen stellen und man konnte bestimmte Dinge einbringen. Und da sind wir wieder bei dem, was ich eben ja schon gesagt habe, dass genau das, alles was an Input vorher geliefert wurde, einfach ignoriert wurde. Und wenn man von Maschinenlisten an den Start sprechen, bei der Ansprache hat der Herr de Maizière das Ganze, was ich dann Open Data nennt vielleicht oder Open Government überhaupt nicht angesprochen. Und hier haben wir These 12. Das sind die online Angebote nutzeorientiert und kostengerecht ausgebaut. Und das ist noch so ein Allgemeinplatz, in dem überhaupt nichts drinsteht. Und das ist dann... Also wir sind wieder da. Es gab ja Input. Und es gibt genug Ideen und so, aber man interessiert sich nicht dafür. So und dann kann man jetzt proaktiv vorher schon was sagen. Das führt zu nichts und man kann reaktionär jetzt hinterher was sagen. Und das wird vielleicht so genauso wenig führen.
Also der Fehler liegt euren Ansicht nach im System. Es gibt die ganzen Ideen schon, aber man kann sie erst dann in der breiten Öffentlichkeit unterbringen.
Also keine von den Thesen, die wir jetzt äußern, ist neu. Sondern das sind alles Sachen, die wir seit Jahren sagen. Und wir haben sie auch schon zusammengefasst und seit Jahren gesagt. Also wir haben nicht Thesen dazu gesagt. Aber im Grunde sahen wir die Notwendigkeit nicht, das nochmal zu sagen, weil wir ja ein Dialog gemacht haben mit der Regierung. Die Regierung ist ja auf uns zugekommen und wir sind vorher auf die Regierung zugekommen und haben gesagt, Leute frag doch mal ein paar Sachverständige, uns zum Beispiel. Und dann haben wir mit denen geredet und die Regierung und der Herr Maizière ist da auch tatsächlich hingekommen und hat dann schön simuliert, dass er uns zuhört. Und hat dann aber genau dasselbe gemacht wie vorher. Also dann hätten wir uns auch sparen können. Und eigentlich wäre natürlich die Idee gewesen, dass die Thesen, die er dann veröffentlicht, unsere Thesen beinhaltet. Aber das ist halt nicht geschehen. Und wenn das nicht ist, dann machen wir halt eine Radiosendung, haben wir uns gesagt.
Wärt ihr nur zufrieden gewesen, wenn Sie sagen, statt seiner eure Thesen gekommen wären? Oder wäre es schon okay gewesen, wenn er gesagt hätte, das ist der Punkt und es gibt folgende Ansichten?
Na, wir haben keinen alleinem Seligmachungsanspruch. Wir sind ja nicht die katholische Kirche hier. Oh, verstehe. Nein, also das heißt, wenn er noch mehr Thesen hat als wir und die Inhaltlichkeit einen Widerspruch darstellt, dann kann er die von mir auch gerne äußern. Solange er nicht dranschreibt, dass es vom CCC ist, ist das in Ordnung.
Okay, das hört sich schon so an, als ob er erst euch fragen soll und dann noch dazudichten darf, wenn er will.
Ja, das ist sowieso eine gute Idee. Das kann ich eigentlich allen Politiker an der Stelle machen.
Möchtest du vielleicht als nächster Bundespräsident?
Nein, nein, der Wolf repräsentiert uns genau richtig. Das ist exakt der Mann, der alle deutschen Eigenschaften perfekt auf den Punkt bringt.
Diese Aussage ist so gemein.
Du böser Mann.
Ich bin böse, ja.
Wir sind also bei den 14 Thesen und Marcel hat angerufen, weil er die toll findet oder nicht. Hallo Marcel.
Hallo, ja, drei.
Ja, wie sieht es aus?
Ja, die sind großartig.
Ne, also ich weiß nicht...
Na warte mal, bis du unsere Thesen hörst.
Naja, also ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl bei unserer Bundesregierung, das sind alles Leute, die haben das Internet nicht verstanden. Und ich glaube, wenn die das Internet erfunden hätten, dann wäre das so wie Telefon. Dann hätte da jeder seine Telefonnummer, und dann muss man da bezahlen und...
Na, Videotext. Wie ist das damals? Tele-Text.
Tele-Text, genau.
Bildschirmtext. Oh, das war doch mal schön zentralistisch. Mit Billing. Hauptkomponente war das Billing.
Gerichtig. Und was ich auch ganz furchtbar finde auch an den Thesen ist diese, naja, ich nenne es mal Prostitution für die Industrie.
Inwiefern?
Na ja, ich meine jetzt gerade mit dem digitalen oder elektrischen Personalausweis und Identifizierbarkeit. Und auch was die Musikindustrie angeht mit Anonymität im Internet ist böse. Und es muss alles nachvollziehbar sein. Und ja, und dann auch die Forderung, die er hat nach mehr Verantwortlichkeit. Und das Internet darf kein rechtsfreier Raum sein.
Da geht es ja nämlich darum, die technische Souveränität muss gewahrt bleiben. Und damit ist gemeint, dass wir in unserem Land die Kompetenz haben sollen für die ganzen wichtigen IT-Projekte, die wir angehen. Und die hat er aber vorher herausgeeckelt. Ja, das ist da, indem er den Hacker-Tool-Verbot paragrafen hat, unsere Regierung gemacht, gegen unsere Ratschläge übrigens. Und jetzt fällt ihnen auf, dass sie keine kompetenten Leute mehr haben. Na also, ich helfe denen nicht mehr.
Wie kommst du überhaupt darauf, dass du zu den nationalen Kernkompetenzen gehörst?
Ich glaube, wir sollten später nochmal genauer über diese Nummer mit Experten. Da haben wir überall noch einzelne Punkte. Marcel, du hast ja jetzt gesagt, die haben alle keine Ahnung. Ich habe mal über den Herrn de Maizière gehört. Da hat jemand gesagt, das Schlimme an dem ist, dass der Wohlarnung hat, aber trotzdem genau das Falsche in Anführungszeichen will.
Ja gut, die Frage ist, das ist das Falsche aus unserer Sicht. Vielleicht ist das aus seiner Sicht genau das Richtige, dass es hängt davon ab, was für einen Hintergrund der hat. Ich meine, ich denke da gerade an Lobbyismus. Ich meine, Messy ist auch ein CDU-Mann, soweit ich, oder? Ja, also ich meine, da liegt er ja mit seinen Forderungen komplett in der Linie seiner Partei.
Ich glaube, er ist auch der Schwager von Schäuble, oder? Das war irgendwie so eine sehr bizarre, jaja.
Na ja, ich meine, Messy muss man ja zu gut halten. Er hat es noch nicht geschafft, so viel Schaden anzurichten als seine zwei Vorgänger.
Ja gut, wir müssen ja vielleicht ein bisschen höher drehen. Erstens hat er noch Zeit. Und zweitens haben wir hoffentlich höhere Ansprüche, als dass sie weniger Schaden machen als die Vorgänger.
Naja, also ich meine, wenn man sich Schäuble anguckt oder auch Schili, dann ist das schon mal ein Riesenfortschritt.
Ja, aber jetzt muss ich nochmal fragen, jetzt sagst du irgendwie, okay, der hat Ahnung, der will vielleicht ganz was anderes. Das liegt daran, dass er herkommt. Der ist ja aber auch gewählt. Vielleicht wollen die das in Deutschland ja so. Vielleicht ist das super. Vielleicht wollen die Leute hier draußen in ein kontrolliertes, personifiziertes, unanonymisiertes und super kompetentes Interesse.
Naja, ich hab den nicht gewählt.
Naja, klar, wir sind schon Demokratie und sozusagen scheinen genug Leute gewesen zu sein.
Naja, wir sind eine parlamentarische Demokratie.
What is not my present?
Wobei, ich glaube, wenn jetzt nochmal Wahlen werden, wird es auch ein bisschen anders aussehen.
Na, die FDP ist auf dem richtigen Weg, war gerade sagen.
Aber zu dem, was die Menschen denn überhaupt wollen, ist ja auch wieder die Frage, wie die Politik ihnen das überhaupt verkauft. Und wenn man das, wir hatten uns eigentlich vorgenommen, auf dieses Thema nicht weiter einzugehen, um ihm nicht den Gefallen zu tun, das weiter zu promoten. Aber insgesamt ist es ja schon so, dass hier die Angst, die man haben muss vor der Technik, auch in der Rede, die er ja gehalten hat, extrem geschürt wird. Es wird immer auf Probleme hingewiesen und darauf, wie schlimm alles ist und welche Probleme wir haben können mit dem Internet und der Freiheit von allen und dem, dass der Staat das nicht regulieren kann. Und das ist ja, wo er dann nahtlos auch wieder anknüpft an die Propaganda von von der Leyen und von allen möglichen anderen Vorgängern.
Aber die Angst ist bei mir schon total real, und zwar die Angst vom Staat. Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe mehr Angst davor, dass da irgendwann mal die Polizei vor der Tür steht und mir hier eine Wohnung auf den Kopf stellt. Oder dass man auf einer Demonstration ist und am Boden liegt und an die Zähne ausgeschlagen werden von den Herren in grün, als dass mehr Terroristen die Wohnung wegsprengen.
Nein, im Moment haben wir ja WM, da verfolgen sie die Fußballfans.
Also ich sag's mal so, wenn dein Bewusstsein für gemeinsame Werte geschärft ist und du selbstbestimmt und eigenverantwortlich arbeitest, dann sollte es eigentlich kein Problem geben.
Lass doch mal die Thesen stecken, das ist ja furchtbar. Das sind These 1 und 2 von de Maizière.
Aber das Problem ist doch, du kannst da gerade in diesem Strafverfolgungsautomat mit Vorwärtsdatenspeicherung und das hat man ja auch in den USA in der Terrorverfolgung gesehen, dass da auch zum größten Teil Unschuldige unter die Räder kommen.
Na hier doch auch, das ist ja kein USA-Phänomen.
Ich meine, das hat doch schon von Netzpolitik in New York auch mal erzählt, dass bei ihm mal das SEK an der Wohnung stand, weil sie ihn mit den Menschen in einen Stockwerk unten runter verwechselt haben.
Jetzt sind wir aber schon wieder beim Reagieren.
Und wir wollen ja heute agieren.
Marcel, letzte Frage an dich. Wenn du sozusagen die 14 Thesen oder wie viele Thesen auch immer du willst zusammenfassen solltest, sind eine positive Forderung. Also wie willst du, dass das Netz aussieht? Wie hört sich das dann an?
Moment, willst du zusammenfassen oder eine Forderung, eine positive?
Pssst, vielleicht merkt er es nicht.
Marcel?
Wie soll das Netz für dich aussehen? Okay, gut. Marcel sagt, das Netz soll am besten wieder so sein, wie es vor 15 Jahren war. Weil das, was heute hier in Deutschland von der Politik angestellt wird, das findet er nicht so derbe Prall. Das geht in beiden Herren vom Chaos Computer Club, die hier sind auch so. Und die wollen heute mal Gegenthesen aufstellen, beziehungsweise andere Thesen oder neue Thesen, wie auch immer das heißt. Wir fangen damit an, nach den Nachrichten, die es zusammen mit Wetter und Verkehr gibt. Vorher haben wir noch ein bisschen Musik, die wie immer, und alle Musik, die es komplett aus dem Netz zum Download gibt, unter Creative Commons Lizenz. Und was das für Musik ist, sage ich euch danach. Oder ihr könnt es nachschlagen im Wiki zur Sendung. Und das findet ihr unter chaosradio.de. Oh mein Gott, was ist das denn für Musik? Fragen sich die Leute gerade, die eben ihr Z-Chat zu dieser Sendung unterwegs sind. Ich kann es euch genau sagen, das ist Yugo Contini, der Song heißt Dewey Square und das ist ein Wunsch. Es ist natürlich so, dass wir das Chaosradio jedes Mal vorher im Netz ankündigen und auch sagen, ihr könnt euch Creative Commons Musik wünschen und manche Leute machen das, so zum Beispiel diesen Track hier. Und wenn ihr andere Musik hören wollt, könnt ihr das einfach vorher einschicken an marcus.richter.fritz.de zum Beispiel oder auf Twitter einfach Bescheid sagen. Es gibt vielfältige Möglichkeiten und insbesondere wird jetzt gerade wieder im ERC-Chat über diese schöne Musik gemeckert und da kann ich nur sagen, das ist eine Mitmachsendung, das heißt, ihr könnt anrufen, nicht nur zur Musik, sondern auch zum Thema. Also es liegt quasi ganz an euch, was hier passiert.
Eure Meinung jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110.
Bevor wir aber weiter reden über die 14 Thesen, wie viele Thesen habt ihr eigentlich mitgebracht?
23 natürlich, aber wir werden nicht alle vorlesen.
Das war klar.
Okay, also 23, wir werden aber nicht alle vorlesen, aber es geht darum, wie der Chaos Computer Club sich die Zukunft der Netzpolitik in Deutschland vorstellt. Heute, letzter Mittwoch im Monat, heißt Chaosradio hier in Blue Moon, zusammen mit Fefe vom Chaos Computer Club, so heißt das, tach. Und Daniel Schmidt. Und es geht anders, eigentlich soll es heute darum gehen, dass wir mal Thesen aufstellen, wie in Deutschland in Zukunft Netzmusik aussehen kann. Das wollen wir auch zusammen mit euch machen.
Netzmusik? Nee, nee, Netzpolitik.
Also Netzpolitik und ihr könnt anrufen, wenn ihr mitmachen wollt unter 0331 77 97 110. Aber bevor wir das machen, hätte ich doch gerne jetzt eine andere Frage stellt, die vielleicht so am Rande zum Thema passt, aber nicht wirklich in den Nachrichten kam gerade. Berührungslose EC-Karten ohne Unterschrift und Geheimnummer.
Das ist doch großartig, oder? Du musst jetzt nicht mehr die EC-Karte kopieren oder klauen, um jemandem Geld abzuheben.
Erste Frage, wisst ihr da drüber was?
Na ja, kontaktlose Karten gibt es schon länger.
Na ja, aber das ist das RFID, oder?
Na was das jetzt konkret ist, weiß ich nicht, aber ich habe immer Ahnung.
Was hat sich von These 14 geleitet, in der man IT-Systeme attraktiv und sicher gestaltet?
Okay, aber zu sagen, das erste, was euch dazu einfällt, ist, aha, interessantes Spielzeug.
Nee, was mir dazu einfällt, ist, dass mir Leute Geld abbuchen können, ohne dass sie meine Karte haben müssen. Ja, bisher muss ja jemand, der mir Geld abheben will, der muss entweder mich dazu bringen, meine Karte irgendwo reinzustecken, oder er muss mich dabei beobachten, wie ich meine Karte irgendwo reinstecke.
Ja, genau, ich meine, das interessante Spielzeug aus der Hackensicht.
Ja, doch, ich will damit nicht spielen, im Gegenteil, ich will das nicht in den Händen haben. Das müssen wir hoffentlich irgendwie abschalten können.
Ähnliche Szenarien gab es doch auch schon mit ID-Cards und so weiter.
Daniel, nur so ein ganz, ganz kleiner Pro-Tipp ins Mikrosprechen hilft.
Ja, das ist alles furchtbar, das war schon immer eine furchtbare Idee. Sie glauben halt, dadurch, dass sie das unter 20 Euro beschränken, das ist halt so eine Bagatellgrenze. Und dann ist es auch egal. Ja genau, so ist das.
Viermal 1999?
Das ist ja mit der Geldkarte auch ähnlich. Da gibt es auch ein Limit. Weil die Leute dem auch nicht vertraut haben. Ach naja.
Aber das finde ich sozusagen die spannende Frage. Wie schnell kann man 20 Euro abhochen? Also hintereinander. Also wenn so eine Karte an einem vorbeigeht.
Das ist doch egal. Nehmen wir an, du stehst im Bus. Und neben dir steht ein Typ. Der hat doch Zeit.
Großartig. Großartige Möglichkeiten. Also ich höre auf als Radiomoderator. Ich glaube, dem wird jetzt wieder eine andere Verdienstmöglichkeit. Heute aber ist das noch nicht der Fall. Und wir reden über Thesen zur Netzpolitik in Deutschland. Wir haben da mal was vorbereitet.
Genau, wir haben da mal was vorbereitet. Wir wollten jetzt hier mal, wir haben uns überlegt, dass wir das in ein paar Blöcke aufteilen. Und der erste Block, da geht es los, damit der Netzzugang ein Grundrecht sein sollte. Also wir finden, jeder soll Zugang zum Internet haben. Genau wie jeder Zugang zum Fernsehen haben soll. Im Moment, wenn jemand bei dir zuhause der Gerichtsvollzieher kommt und räumt dir deine Möbel aus, dann darf er den Fernseher nicht wegnehmen oder bzw. er muss einen Fernseher dalassen. Auch wenn es nur ein schrottiger schwarz-weiß Fernseher ist, weil das nämlich ein Instrument ist, über das du deine politische Willensbildung vollziehen kannst. Deswegen darf dir der Fernseher nicht weggenommen werden. Und wir finden, das sollte mit dem Internet genauso sein. Mindestens, wenn nicht noch mehr als beim Fernseher. Denn das Internet löst das Fernsehen zunehmender als Medium für Nachrichten.
Und es ist nicht nur unidirektional, sondern es geht auch in beide Richtungen. Man kann sich sogar beteiligen an der Debatte und an der Willensbildung.
Also Internet muss sein.
Nicht nur Internet, wir sagen sogar Breitbandinternet muss sein.
Das ist doch mal die nächste Frage gewesen. Weil bei dem Fernseher und dem, wie heißt das, der Typ, der das Geld einkriegt, der Griechsvollzieher, das ist ja wohl irgendwie, man kann das wohl irgendwie so machen, also wenn es irgendwie der Super-3-Meter-Plasma-irgendwas, kann man sagen, okay, den musst du verkaufen, aber es gibt sozusagen eine Mindestanforderung, es muss ein Fernseher sein?
Du musst ein Fernseher, müssen sie dir lassen. Man kann dir auch einen anderen Schrott hinstellen, aber du musst halt ein Fernseher haben.
Aber was ist denn genau die Minimalanforderung an den Internetanschluss, den dir da jetzt stellt?
Das haben wir jetzt technisch nicht ausgespeckt, aber wir finden, es sollte mindestens ein DSL sein. Ja, also ein Megabit mindestens, würde ich jetzt mal persönlich sagen, aber das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie meine CCC, sondern ist jetzt so Pi mal Daumen von mir. Aber ich finde, es sollte genug sein, dass man irgendwie auch mal ein paar Videos gucken kann, der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk stellt inzwischen seine Nachrichtssendungen auch als YouTube-Video flashmäßig ins Netz.
Man hat ja nur sieben Tage Zeit, die zu gucken.
Genau, und das ist ja furchtbar. Das heißt, man muss einen dicken Internetzugang haben, damit man die alle gucken kann. Und das finden wir, ist dann auch eine Grundanforderung, die jeder Bürger als Recht haben soll.
Auch um sie streamen zu können, um sie dann selbst zu verwahren, da niemand anderes gespeichert. Das ist ja ein Problem vielleicht.
Da kommen wir auch nochmal zu. Aber eine weitere Sache, die daraus folgt, ist, dass man es auch nicht abstellen darf. Also eine der Forderungen, die in letzter Zeit häufiger mal gehört wird, ist, wenn jemand dreimal erwischt wird via MP3s Cloud, dann machen wir ihm sein Internet aus. Und das kommt nicht in Frage. Das ist ein Grundrecht. Das kann man nicht ausstellen.
Fertig.
Wer soll das bezahlen?
Na, die Bürger selbst sollen genug Geld haben. Also der Hartz-IV-Satz muss dann auch genug einkalkuliert haben, damit der Bürger sich das leisten kann.
Okay, aber sozusagen ist das nicht so eine Art öffentlich gefördertes...
Na, das kommt ja auch selber raus. Ob du es jetzt öffentlich förderst oder ob du sagst, das besteuern wir nicht oder was weiß ich. Also das ist am Ende Toffschieberei. Aber im Grunde sagen wir, jeder Bürger, der will, und das sind hoffentlich alle, sollen in die Lage versetzt werden, sich ein Internet zusammen zu besorgen.
Und da gibt es noch die andere spannende Frage. Es soll ja tatsächlich Gegenden geben. Da gibt es noch gar kein DSL?
Genau, also das ist auch so ein Ding. Das ist übrigens sogar eine der Thesen von Herrn de Maizière. Der sagt nämlich auch, breitbanden Internet für alle. Aber die sagen das seit, was nicht, 12 Jahren. Und deswegen sagen wir, Leute, macht doch mal. Worauf wartet ihr eigentlich?
Habt ihr einen Vorschlag, wie das gehen kann?
Na, das kann ganz schnell gehen, wenn man der Telekom sagt, ihr dürft überhaupt nur noch keine Anschlüsse verkaufen, außer ihr bietet überall Anschlüsse an. So lief das nämlich früher mit der Post. Und so lief es auch nach dem Monopolaufbrechen im Telefonbereich mit der Telekom. Wenn jemand auf einer Hallig wohnt, in der Nordsee, dann kann die Telekom nicht sagen, ne, dem mach ich kein Telefon.
Okay, also sie wird gesetzlich verpflichtet.
Eine Grundversorgung. Alle Leute müssen DSL kriegen, fertig.
Steht das irgendwie, also mal davon abgesehen, dass es natürlich jetzt an der Realisierung mangelt? Also sagen, es gibt ja anscheinend den Willen oder so.
Das ist kein technisches Problem, an dem es mangelt. Sondern es kostet halt Geld. Und wenn man die Telekom nicht zwingt, oder beziehungsweise man kann ja die Branche zwingen, man kann sagen, die Branche muss das machen. Und wenn die es nicht freiwillig tun, dann macht es der Staat und wir stellen es denen in Rechnung. Also das kann man ja alles machen. Das sind alles irgendwie Umsetzungssachen. Wenn man wollte, könnte man das tun, aber es will keiner.
Das heißt aber, in der Politik sieht ihr auch keinen Widerstand gegen das Konzept, sondern nur die lahmarschigkeit, dass es nicht passiert.
Genau, das ist lahmarschigkeit und das Geld wird lieber für andere Sachen ausgegeben. Was ja nicht unbedingt schlecht ist, aber es wird eben nicht gut ausgegeben. Sondern eher für, wir bauen lieber Mautbrücken damit. Internetanschluss. Was ja auch breitband Internet für alle ist, wenn man drüber nachdenkt. Die haben ja in die Breite der Bundesrepublik Mautbrücken mit dickem Internetanschluss gelegt. Und wir finden, mit dem Geld hätten sie lieber Internet in die Dörfer bringen sollen.
Das ist also die erste These. Jeder sollte Internet haben. Und zwar auch so, dass man Videos gucken kann. Und die Frage ist natürlich, was ihr davon haltet. Findet ihr die These gut oder schlecht?
Ja, Moment, wir haben noch zwei andere...
Die Sache ist, dass ich es zwischendurch immer mal sagen würde. Also wer Fefe noch nicht kennt, falls es da jemand gibt, Fefe redet gerne viel, deswegen muss man inzwischen...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das ist genau das, was ich meine. Und deswegen will ich jetzt mal schnell sagen... 0331-70-97-110 Genau, also es geht natürlich auch darum, dass ihr sagt, was ihr davon haltet und welche Thesen ihr dabei haben wollt. So, und du hast jetzt sozusagen einen Themenkomplex gebastelt?
Genau, der erste ist eben Internet für alle. Und dazu gehört auch zu, wenn man den Leuten Internet legt, muss das auch netzneutral sein. Also netzneutral heißt zum Beispiel, dass die Telekom nicht kommen kann auf deinem DSL-Anschluss und sagen kann, Google zahlt aber keine Prämie dafür, dass sie schnell zugestellt werden, deswegen stellen wir die jetzt langsam zu. Also das ist ein Geschäftsmodell, über das die Internetprovider nachdenken seit geraumer Zeit. Also einfach das bestimmte Datenverkehr bevorzugt. Genau, andersrum. Wir haben zwei mögliche Situationen. Die erste ist, die Leitung ist tatsächlich voll und der Provider muss jetzt überlegen, welchen Traffic er zuerst durchlässt. Das ist noch halbwegs legitim, darüber kann man reden. Aber die andere Sache ist daraus ein Geschäftsmodell zu machen. Also, dass die Telekom Google erpresst und sagt, wenn ihr schnell abrufbar sein wollt von unseren Usern, dann müsst ihr nochmal zahlen. Oder andersrum, dass die Telekom sagt oder Vodafone, irgendein Mobiltelefonbetreiber sagt, wir wollen aber nicht, dass ihr Skype macht oder Voice-over-IP, deswegen stellen wir das gar nicht oder nur sehr langsam zu. Das ist auch Netzneutralität. Also wenn du einen Zugang zum Netz anbietest, dann darfst du nicht inhaltlich entscheiden, das stelle ich jetzt aber zu und das hier nicht. Sondern dann wird alles zugestellt und du musst neutral dem Traffic gegenüber sein.
Ist das was, was sozusagen eine Forderung ist, wo ihr sagt, das muss so bleiben, wie es jetzt ist, oder ist das schon derzeit, also ich meine, okay...
Das muss noch weitergehen, als es im Moment ist.
Ja, das wird schon in den letzten Jahren und hat sich das auch technisch schon verändert. Also dass eben viel mehr der Provider viel mehr reguliert am Anschluss und da aus Sicht des Providers optimiert oder wie auch immer technisch das etwas anders zustellt als früher. Also da wird schon viel mehr geschaut, wie möchte man das von Provider-Seite haben, was ist da irgendwie am rentabelsten und so weiter, ohne dass man eben dem Nutzer das überlässt.
Das ist ja auch nicht bösartig. Also das will ich jetzt hier nicht aufkommen lassen, dass die uns alle abzocken wollen.
Aber man kann halt... Mein bitteren Datendurchsatz bei einer deutschen Fernsehfirma ist also mäßig.
Ja, natürlich. Also nun stell dir mal vor, du bist ein Internetprovider und du bietest deinen Usern Video-Streaming an, die Weltmeisterschaft dürfen die sich streamen. Und jetzt ist deine Leitung aber voll, weil die Leute alle torrenten. Und dann ist schon nachvollziehbar, dass der Anbieter sagt, naja, dann leite ich aber hier meinen eigenen Streaming-Kram in Priorität weiter.
Aber das ist so eine feine Grenze, eine Grenze, die gezogen werden muss zwischen technischer Notwendigkeit.
Genau, das ist nicht komplett unnachvollziehbar, die Idee, dass man den Traffic priorisieren will. Sondern es wird wahrscheinlich nicht ohne gehen, denn keiner legt so viel Leitung, dass jeder mit vollem Zugang ganztägig saugen kann.
Ich glaube, es gab dazu sogar schon mal ein Chaosradio. Natürlich.
Wie gesagt, die Thesen sind alle nicht neu, die wir hier aufstellen. Wir stellen sie jetzt nur noch mal zusammen auf, um eine schöne Thesenliste zu haben.
Wir haben jetzt gleich jemanden, das Chaosradio International gehört, aus Sizilien, der anruft. Aber sag noch schnell, dass die dritte These aus dem Paket enthält für alle ist.
Genau, die dritte These ist, dass die Daten im Internet den Kernbereich der Privatsphäre betreffen, und zwar nicht nur die inhaltlichen Daten, also die E-Mails, die du verschickst, sondern auch die Bewegtaten, um die es jetzt gerade bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ging. Und deswegen darf nichts davon angeguckt oder gespeichert werden. Das möchten wir, das ist im Moment schon so, weil wir es erfordert haben letztendlich. Aber es soll bitte so bleiben. Also das möchten wir nochmal extra auf den Tisch legen, das bleibt so.
Da ist aber ein kurzes Update, das ist doch so, dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung im Prinzip nochmal kommt. Ja, genau.
Deswegen sagen wir das jetzt auch gerade. Das soll bitte so bleiben, wie es jetzt ist.
Alles klar.
Und eine Winzigkeit haben wir noch, wenn du zwei Datenbanken hast, dann ist die Zusammenführung der Datenbanken eine neue Qualität über den Inhalt der Datenbanken hinaus. Also sagen wir mal, du lädst deine Daten beim sozialen Netz hoch und du lädst andere Daten bei YouTube hoch. Und wenn jetzt jemand kommt und beide Daten hat, dann darf er sie trotzdem nicht zusammenführen, obwohl die veröffentlicht wird. Das ist eine weitere Sache. Wir sagen, es sind zusätzliche Erkenntnisse, die über deine Person gewonnen werden können, wenn öffentliche Daten aus verschiedenen Quellen zusammengeführt werden oder auch nicht öffentliche Daten. Und daher ist das ein weiterer Schritt über der Veröffentlichung der Daten. Und du darfst nicht einfach Daten zusammenführen, nur weil du sie hast.
Na das ist aber, wie soll das durchgesetzt werden?
Na, das ist nicht alles irgendwie als gesetzgemeint, sondern auch als Grundlage, um darüber zu reden.
Ja, das ist schon klar.
Also die Frage ist, wenn du jemanden dabei erwischt, wie er große Datendossiers erstellt, dann kannst du sagen, das wollen wir aber nicht. Also ob man es jetzt aktiv danach fanken kann, ist eine Sache. Aber wenn du jemanden erwischt dabei, dann kannst du dir natürlich trotzdem belangen.
Es gibt ja heute schon ganz viele Portale, die nichts anderes machen, eigentlich als alles zu datameinen, was man so findet, und das dann an einer Seite anzubieten. Und dann finde ich auf einer Übersichtsseite auf einmal meine Telefonnummern zusammen mit allen Social-Network-Profilen, die ich so habe und was auch immer sonst noch zu mir.
Genau das.
Und das ist das einzige Geschäftsmodell, was diese Firma hat. Und die hat mich weder gefragt, ob ich damit einverstanden bin, noch irgendetwas anderes gemacht, sondern die bedient sich nur irgendwelcher Daten, die von mir irgendwo zu finden sind.
Nicht unterbunden, aber nur mit Zustimmung. Also wenn du nichts dagegen hast.
Aber es ist in der Umsetzung natürlich sehr schwierig, weil das ja...
Natürlich.
Okay.
Aber ich meine, wir müssen darüber reden. Das ist ein Problem, das wir jetzt haben. Das muss auf den Tisch.
Ihr sagt, das ist eine gute Idee. Und euch ist aber auch klar, dass es schwierig ist, umzusetzen.
Genau. Da müssen wir gemeinsam nachdenken, was wir da tun wollen. Also wir können jetzt Kopf in Sand machen. Das ist die aktuelle Schlagung.
Ich glaube ja, ein gutes Konzept wäre es, keinen Account bei Studio4Z zu haben. Natürlich.
Also das ist im Moment auch unsere Ansage. Wenn ihr die Daten nicht ins Netz tut, dann können die auch nicht zusammengeführt werden. Aber das ist eben nur partiell realistisch.
Das stimmt. Martin macht in Sizilien Zivildienst und hat hier angerufen, weil er auch etwas zur Debatte beitragen möchte. Hallo Martin.
Na, dann schließ mal los.
Es ist ziemlich warm hier unten.
Hier nicht viel anders.
Nichts Besonderes. Zu welchen Thesen möchtest du etwas beitragen? Oder hast du ganz neue eigene?
Also, ihr habt mir gerade schon das Stichwort gegeben. Unerwarteterweise. Mir geht es auch um den Datenschutz. Und zwar habe ich die Befürchtung, so wie jetzt der Tonfall am Anfang der Sendung schon kam, dass wir vielleicht in dieser Diskussion oder auch die Hacker-Bewegung, die Geeks, die Blogger im Allgemeinen ein bisschen Gefahr laufen, im ständigen Misstrauen gegenüber dem Staat, die eigentlichen Gefahren ein bisschen zu vernachlässigen. Ich fühle mich nicht mehr zurzeit viel mehr bedroht von den großen Konzernen als vom Staat, was jetzt meine Privatsphäre und meine Daten im Netz betrifft. Und ich erinnere mich noch an die Unabhängigkeitserklärung des KuiperSpace, wo es hieß, hier Regierungen der industriellen Welt, ihr müden Giganten aus Schleif und Stahl, im Namen der Zukunft bitte ich euch Vertreter einer vergangenen Zeit, lasst uns in Ruhe.
Was ist genau das, was du da gerade zitiert hast?
Die Unabhängigkeitserklärung des KuiperSpace vor Jahren, Jahrzehnten, gar nicht so lange, 1996, da habe ich ja sogar schon gelebt, veröffentlicht wurde. Und ich glaube allmählich, dass wir in eine andere Richtung einschlagen müssen. Ich glaube nämlich, der Staat ist notwendig im Netz. Und der Staat muss im Netz vernünftig regulieren. Wie ich, wenn ich jetzt erlebe, wie alle meine Mitbewohner hier, wir sind hier zu zehnt, die ganze Zeit Facebook benutzen und ihr ihr halbes oder fast ihr ganzes Privatleben im Netz da verbringen, da kann man sich da ganz schwer entziehen. Ich habe auch einen Facebook-Account dagegen. Deshalb, obwohl ich da eigentlich gerne raushehe. Oder wenn man sich überlegt, was für eine Macht Google hat, die wissen eigentlich alles über mich. Wenn man mal so Stückchen mal zunimmt, was ich suche, was ich für E-Mails schreibe, mein Kalender, was weiß ich, je nachdem, welche Applikation ich da nutze. Und ich frage mich, ob es nicht wichtig ist, dass das Internet von demokratisch gewählten Regierungen reguliert wird. Statt von den Providern, von so halb privaten Höhlen wie iCan. Also von lauter Konzernen und privaten Institutionen, die eigentlich noch viel schlechter kontrolliert, viel schlechter reguliert sind als der Staat.
Jetzt haben wir die Sache, die, dass bei den ganzen Thesen auch schon gesagt wird, naja, was der Herr de Maizière aufs Papier gebracht hat, ist jetzt ganz viel auch Lobbyzeug. Wie würdest du denn sicherstellen, dass der Staat dann quasi in deinem Sinne entscheidet und nicht im Sinne der großen Firmen?
Na, ich würde sogar noch einen Schritt weiter gehen. Also du kannst ja sagen, Google hat ja kein Interesse daran, deine Daten zu missbrauchen im Moment. Alles, was sie gewinnen können, ist, sie können ein bisschen Geld machen, wenn sie es verkaufen, aber dann haben sie, wenn es rauskommt, ein riesen Imageproblem und sind draußen. Deswegen wird Google im Moment andere Sachen tun, als deine Daten zu missbrauchen. Die Regierung auf der anderen Seite hat nicht nur ein Interesse daran, deine Daten zu missbrauchen, sie tut es auch ständig. Wir erwischen die ja ständig dabei, dass irgendwelche Sachen verloren gehen, dass irgendwelche Datenbanken zusammengeführt werden, dass das gemeinsame Abhörzentrum eingerichtet werden, dass Datenbanken zusammengeführt werden. Jetzt wird gerade ein Register geführter Zensus durchgeführt, dem eigentlich auch kein Deutscher zugestimmt hat. Also es ist natürlich gerechtfertigt zu sagen, die bösen Firmen können alles fiese Sachen mit uns tun und der Staat muss uns retten, aber in der Praxis ist es eher so, dass der Staat fiese Sachen mit uns tut und uns die Firmen retten. So traurig das ist. Man muss sich natürlich gegen beide wehren, aber das ist nicht so einseitig zu klären, dass man sagen kann, hab vor denen Angst und vor denen weniger. Oder im Grunde muss es so laufen, dass du dich selber schützt, indem du Datenverschlusstung einsetzt. Und das ist auch eine unserer Thesen, zu denen wir noch kommen werden.
Datenverschlusstung ist Grundschutz. Wenn du bezwungen bist, gegenüber Google kann ich keine Datenverschlusstung einsetzen. Oder ich keinen Mensch von meinen Freunden habe. Also ich weiß, ich habe noch ein PGT-Programm benutzt, aber kein Mensch von meinen Freunden benutzt.
Das ist nur eine Frage deines Bildungsniveaus. Und das, wie sehr du die digitale Welt, in der du dich bewegst, verstehst. Und das ist auch natürlich eines der größten Probleme bei dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Genau, das stimmt nicht. Das ist nämlich nicht die Frage von Martins Bildungsniveau oder von meinem Bildungsniveau.
Oder dem seiner Freunde.
Genau, das ist die Frage des Bildungsniveaus meines Umfelds.
Dann ist das dein Bildungsauftrag, den du hast, um allen anderen Leuten, die du kennst, die sich dieser Probleme nicht bewusst sind, das zu vermitteln. Und wenn du ein Recht hast auf Anonymität und Tools einsetzen kannst, um anonym zu bleiben, dazu kommen wir ja dann auch nochmal, dann kannst du auch gegenüber Google das verschleiern. Du kannst auch einfach anstatt Google Scroogle benutzen und hast einen Dienst, der darauf basiert, dass er eben diese ganzen Daten nicht erhebt. Wie auch immer. Es gibt ja verschiedenste Möglichkeiten. Egal wie, es ist wichtig, dass jeder eben versteht, wie komplex diese technische Welt ist, in der er sich bewegt. Und dass er eben unter Umständen, wenn er Facebook benutzt oder andere Dienste, damit Daten über sich preisgibt. Und das ist ja eine Entscheidung, die dir alleine als Verbraucher irgendwie obliegt. Das musst du entscheiden und du musst entscheiden, wo du das abwegst.
Ich glaube, das ist in Einzelfällen nicht meine persönliche Entscheidung, sondern es ist eine Entscheidung der Gesellschaft von vielen, die hier auch alleine nicht treffen können. Und ich glaube, die wichtigste Frage ist einfach, ob es gut ist, dass die Kontrolle des Internets so bleibt, wie sie im Moment ist, nämlich vollständig oder fast vollständig in der Hand von Providern, privaten Firmen.
Das ist doch überhaupt nicht der Fall.
Das ist auch demokratisch.
Martin, einen kleinen Moment mal. Also wir werden es wahrscheinlich nicht mehr sozusagen, also ihr werdet euch nicht mehr einigen.
Nein, aber die Fakten stimmen schon nicht.
Aber die Frage ist, wie soll denn so eine Kontrolle aussehen, Martin? Also wie viel Mittel wärst du bereit, dem Staat in die Hand zu geben?
Wieso nicht nur eine staatliche Suchmaschine zum Beispiel, so wie es auch öffentlich-meichliche Medien gibt? Wieso soll die AAD nicht für eine Suchmaschine verantwortlich sein?
Warte mal, das gibt es in China. Weißt du, wie gut das funktioniert? Kannst du dir ausdenken. Übrigens, ich höre hier immer privatwirtschaftliche Provider.
Was glaubst du, wem die Telekom gehört?
Ich habe heute den Livestream zur Bundespräsidentenwahl gesehen. Das war großartig. Das war ausgewogen. Insofern haben wir da eine andere Situation als in China.
Also du hättest sagen gerne, dass die wichtigsten Angebote im Netz von einer staatlichen oder staatlich beauftragten Stelle realisiert werden. Also eine Suchmaschine, ein soziales Netzwerk.
Von der UNO oder der Europäischen Union oder einer legitimeren Institution als den Providern, die letztendlich doch nur an den Aktienmärkten gehen.
Ich glaube, wir haben hier noch einen anderen Bildungsauftrag gerade. Nein, aber guck mal, die Telekom gehört dem Staat. Unserem Staat. E plus gehört KPN. Weißt du, wem KPN gehört? Den Niederlanden. Also du kannst mal durchgehen, den ganzen Provider. Da bleibt nicht viel übrig, wenn du die in Kontrolle der Regierung rausziehst. Und wenn du dir anguckst, wo tatsächlich Daten missbraucht werden, dann ist das in überwiegender Mehrheit die Regierung. Und eines der Hauptkritikpunkte an Google war über die Jahre, nicht, dass sie die Daten sammeln für sich selbst und missbrauchen, sondern dass sie die Daten sammeln und die Regierung es dann beschlagnahmen kann, um es zu missbrauchen. Also natürlich kann man geteilter Meinung darüber sein, von wem du jetzt lieber missbraucht werden willst. Und deswegen ist die einzig richtige Antwort, die wir geben können, ist, dass du dich vor allen schützt. Aber hier die Argumentation, wir trauen den Firmen nicht, deswegen gehen wir zu der Regierung, die ist ein kompletter Mumpitz.
Also ich weiß auch, dass verschiedenste privatwirtschaftliche Konzerne, die eben an solchen Sachen beteiligt sind, auch nicht unbedingt, also die Leute, die für sowas verantwortlich sind, nicht unbedingt glücklich sind darüber, dass eben etwas beschlagnahmt werden kann. Und dass es sicherlich auch Bestrebungen gibt, zu überlegen, was kann man tun, damit eben niemand etwas beschlagnahmen kann oder damit selbst in den Netzen dieser Suchmaschinen oder wie auch immer Sachen so anonym sind, dass niemand dort wiretappen kann oder sonst wie eben was mitschneiden kann. Also es ist ja für die privatwirtschaftlich gesehen auch immer ein erhöhter Aufwand. Wenn jemand kommt und will Vorratsdatenspeicherung machen, ist das für keinen der Provider eigentlich attraktiv, weil das einen erhöhten Mehraufwand bedeutet und man dafür zusätzliche technische Infrastruktur installieren muss, die einem keiner bezahlt und die man wieder umlegen muss. Also das Interesse in der Privatwirtschaft da irgendwie Daten anzuhäufen ist, würde ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt sagen, besonders groß. Zumindest nicht, wenn man ihnen ein Umfeld bietet, in dem sie das nicht tun müssen. Und dann, wie Fefe gesagt hat, es gibt natürlich vielleicht ein kommerzielles Interesse und sicherlich ist es für Google gut zu wissen, wie das User-Verhalten aussieht, damit man entsprechend dann Ads platzieren kann oder so. Aber das ist nicht das Kernproblem, über das wir hier reden.
Dabei würde das nicht das Kernproblem werden, wenn es keine staatliche Kontrolle mehr gäbe?
Die gibt es ja jetzt auch nicht. Hat Herr de Maizière ja selbst schon bemängelt, dass es kein deutsches Google gibt, dass er irgendwie kontrollieren kann, sondern dass das ein amerikanischer Konzern ist, der seinen Gesetzen oder dem, wie er sich die Welt so vorstellt, eben nicht unterliegt?
Na, es gibt doch ein Projekt sogar von der EU oder von Frankreich, war das glaube ich. Es gibt so ein EU-Projekt, so wir brauchen jetzt ein Gegengugel. Aber ich meine, am Ende schallt das sowas daran, dass es keiner benutzen will. Weil ein Staat einfach viel weniger Interesse daran hat, selbst wenn sie das fertig kriegen, die Gelder auszulegen, um das am Laufen zu halten. Ich meine jetzt nicht den Betrieb, sondern was Google an Forschung ausgibt, um immer mehr Kram einzubauen oder auch Bing oder andere Konkurrenten, die es da gibt, das ist ein echter großer Haufen Geld. Und denen wird keine Regierung in die Hand nehmen wollen. Das ist das erste, was weggespart wird, wenn mal wieder irgendwie ein Steuerloch ist. Na, könnt ihr mal dran drauf lassen, natürlich. Die Regierung hat ja jetzt schon... Ich meine, wir reden über Suche, aber rede mal auf dem Schritt vor der Suche. Die Daten, in denen du suchen willst, haben ja auch vom öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk im Moment, unter anderem. Und da spart der Staat gerade ein. Wie kommst du denn darauf, dass die Geld ausgeben wollen, um eine Suchmaschine zu bauen? Außer, um es zu missbrauchen. Nein, aber ich meine, überleg dir das doch mal. Welchen Grund könnte dein Staat haben, eine Suchmaschine anzubieten, außer, um sie zu missbrauchen?
Nein, ernsthaft, das einzige Argument für ein Staat, sowas zu tun, wäre Strafverfolgung. Das ist aber sozusagen... Martin, deine Verbindung wird gerade nicht so richtig geil. Man kann dich kaum noch verstehen. Und ich glaube, das ist jetzt aber eine Ansichtssache. Das ist natürlich dann die Frage, unterstellt man dem Staat, dass er grundsätzlich böse ist, oder hält man ihm zugute, dass es vielleicht doch nicht der Fall ist. Das ist, glaube ich, eine Frage, die wir heute nicht abschließend klären werden. Ich würde aber bitten, dass ich das sehr spannendes Thema finde, also Staat oder Industrie oder beide, weglassen oder nicht kontrollieren. Das ist genau das, wo wir ja noch anrufen können. 0331 70 97 8 10.
Wir vertrauen natürlich niemandem.
Martin? Ich würde das Thema an dieser Stelle dann abbrechen, weil wir haben ja noch zu den 23 Thesen noch ein paar mehr am Start. Alles klar. Dann bis dann. Ihr könnt aber, wie gesagt, weiterhin anrufen. 0331 70 97 8 10 ist die Nummer. Was ist denn der nächste Themenkomplex?
Der nächste Themenkomplex sind öffentliche Daten, private Daten, Anonymität und Whistleblower.
Öffentliche Daten, private Daten.
Das ist eigentlich auch ein Teil der Hackerethik.
Das heißt, das ist auch wieder nichts Neues, könnte man so sagen.
Ja, die meisten hier sagen, es ist wirklich keine Revolution, die wir hier gerade verkünden.
Was ist denn da die grundsätzliche Forderung in dem Themenkomplex? Oder die erste These?
Die erste Komplex, also der erste Teil des Komplexes, sind öffentliche Daten und da haben wir ein paar grundlegende Forderungen. Nämlich sagen wir, wenn Ergebnisse erlangt wurden, indem Steuermittel eingesetzt wurden, also zum Beispiel Forschung an der Uni oder irgendein EU-Projekt, da gibt es ja viele von und da fließt ein Großteil des Geldes nicht an die Uni, sondern in Firmen. Wenn die jetzt zu irgendeinem Ergebnis kommen, dann gehört das auch uns, denn wir haben dafür gezahlt. Wir sagen, öffentlich, also mit Steuermitteln finanzierte Ergebnisse und Inhalte müssen allgemein frei sein, müssen ins Internet gestellt werden, kostenlos abrufbar für alle.
Maschinenlesbar?
Maschinenlesbar, genau. Und was wir damit meinen, können wir vielleicht ein bisschen konkretisieren. Das sind zum Beispiel Sachen wie die Karte Deutschlands. Da würde man jetzt denken, Deutschland sind wir, die Karte kann ich einfach runterladen. Stimmt nicht, die muss man kaufen. Von unserer Regierung, da gibt es eine Agentur, die damit befasst ist, diese Daten zu verkaufen. Und das ist doch unglaublich. Ich meine, wir haben mit Steuermitteln dafür bezahlt, dass diese Daten gemacht werden. Und warum soll ich jetzt dafür zahlen, die zu kriegen? Das stimmt doch was nicht. Nicht nur ich, auch eine Firma, die jetzt einen Stadtplan bauen will. Also das wären zum Beispiel Daten.
Das heißt aber auch, die Daten, die mit Steuergeld gemacht wurden, sollen auch für kommerzielle Zerke zur Verfügung stehen?
Ja, die sollen so zur Verfügung stehen, dass jeder, ob kommerziell oder privat, damit machen kann, was er möchte. Dann muss auch niemand beim Staat sich mehr ausdenken, welche Angebote man zur Verfügung stellt, die der Nutzer dann nutzen kann, wie auch in den Thesen hier, dass er so drinne steht. Wir hatten ja hier diesen einen Punkt, dass die, eine Sekunde, genau das Online-Angebot nutzerorientiert und kostengerecht ausgebaut werden soll. Das heißt, irgendjemand interpretiert, was wollen die Nutzer denn überhaupt haben und das wird zur Verfügung gestellt, so ähnlich wie das heute vielleicht schon ist. Und das ist eigentlich doch der falsche Ansatz. Wieso werden nicht Daten, die vorhanden sind, eben maschinenlesbar zur Verfügung gestellt und wir überlassen den Rest der Kreativität der Masse? Und wenn ich mir heute ein Tool bauen will, das irgendwelche Statistiken vom Statistischen Bundesamt auswerte, dann kann ich das machen. Und dann kann ich da draußen eine iPhone-App machen oder sonst was und kann das einfach irgendwo anderen Leuten frei zur Verfügung stellen.
Also es geht auch um andere Daten. Es geht zum Beispiel auch um Papers, die an Unis geschrieben werden. Oder Doktorarbeiten.
Also wir sind natürlich gearbeitet. Aber es muss doch wahrscheinlich irgendwo eine Grenze haben. Denn gerade was der Staat erhebt an Daten, ist ja auch oft persönliches Zeug.
Das kann ja anonymisiert werden.
Deswegen reden wir hier von öffentlichen Daten. Also es geht nicht um deine Bewegtaten beim Telefon, sondern es geht um Daten, die uns alle betreffen. Also zum Beispiel die Katastardaten, wo welche Straße lang geht. Wo ein Haus steht. Sowas zum Beispiel. Nicht unbedingt wer da wohnt, da kann man drüber nachdenken. Aber so Daten, also alle Erfindungen, die an Unis gemacht werden oder an Firmen, unter Einwirkung, also unter Sponsorship durch Steuergelder oder EU-Projekte, sollen allgemein frei sein. Das ist der große Punkt. Also die anderen Daten sind eher Folgerungen daraus. Aber der große Punkt, der im Moment nicht so ist, ist, also ich kann als Firma hingehen, an einem EU-Projekt teilnehmen, kann mir das praktisch vollständig finanzieren lassen. Also auf dem Papier heißt es eben nicht vollständig, sondern höchstens N-Prozent, aber da kann man sich drum rummogeln. Also ich kann Geld von der EU nehmen, kann mit dem Geld was entwickeln, kann es patentieren und verkaufen und der Staat kriegt nichts dafür. Das heißt, ich werde quasi von den Steuerzahlern dafür bezahlt, das zu tun, was ich eigentlich eh hätte tun sollen, nur normalerweise mit einem Bankkredit mache. Aber im Moment kriegen wir praktisch keine Gegenleistung, außer, dass die Sache überhaupt gemacht wird. Also die Argumentation im Moment ist, naja, das ist doch Wirtschaftsförderung und wir machen hier Forschungsstandort und so.
Das heißt, alles, also alle Daten und alle Erkenntnisse...
Ich finde, wenn du, genau, ich, also ich persönlich, aber auch noch andere Leute finden, wenn Steuergelder da reingeflossen sind, dann ist das mit meinem Geld gemacht worden als Steuerzahler und dann gehört das auch mir. Und wenn du das nicht gut findest als Firma, dann nimmst du halt keine EU-Projektgelder.
Oder finanzierst das selbst. Und das Ganze gehört zu den Thesen zur Netzpolitik in Deutschland, wie sich der Chaos Computer Club das gerade vorstellt und das wird präsentiert in dieser Sendung.
Bitte wie meinen?
So lange das rote Licht leuchtet, ist das Mikrofon an. Ich möchte aber jetzt noch mal ganz allgemein sagen, wir reden heute über die Thesen zur Netzpolitik in Deutschland. Der Herr Bundesinnenminister de Maizière hat 14 davon an Start gebracht, die beim Chaos Computer Club nicht so derbe auf Gegenliebe gestoßen sind, könnte man so formulieren. Und Fefe und Daniel Schmidt vom Chaos Computer Club sind heute hier und präsentieren mal einen neuen Entwurf von Thesen. Und wir sind dabei, dass es jetzt gerade um öffentliche Daten geht. Also Daten, die durch Steuer finanziert wurden und die, sagt Fefe, öffentlich zur Verfügung gestellt werden, es sei denn, es sind persönliche Daten. Ihr könnt während der ganzen Sendung auch noch anrufen 0331 70 97 110. Und weil ihr das könnt, könnt ihr natürlich hier auch was sagen, so wie die Rieke. Die möchte zu dem Thema was sagen, was wir jetzt... Ach, Rieke, höre ich gerade. Die Regie sagt gerade Rieke.
Oh, das ist ja peinlich, Jens.
Ja, aber wirklich. Es geht darum... Guten Abend. Um etwas, was wir vorhin besprochen hatten, dass ihr nämlich sagt, also es muss schon so sein, dass jeder User sich selber informiert und selber sozusagen entscheidet, was er mit seinen Daten macht. Und deswegen ist auch Reglementation nicht sozusagen das A und O aller Dinge.
Ja, sehr gerne. Erst mal schönen guten Abend in die Runde und ins Fritzland. Ja, was für eine Art User bin ich? Ich bin ein User, der sich schon für ziemlich emanzipiert hält, dafür, dass er weiß, dass es da draußen so etwas gibt wie Krypto. Ich benutze es selbst nur nicht, weil ich noch nicht dahinter gestiegen bin, wie es funktioniert. Ich habe jetzt sieben Jahre Universität hinter mir. Das heißt, ich habe auch einen relativ hohen Bildungsstand. Ich habe Freunde aus dem Hacker-Spektrum. Hier in Leipzig gibt es auch das tolle Saatlab, wo ich öfter mal rumhänge. Schöne Grüße, falls von dort jemand zuhört. Das ist sozusagen unser Hacker-Space hier.
Warum hast du es dir noch nicht zeigen lassen von denen? Warum hast du es dir noch nicht zeigen lassen von denen?
Na ja, ab und zu heißt, ich gehe da in zwei Wochen einmal hin und da ist einfach sozusagen, weißt du, es ist kommunikativ einfach ein unterschiedlicher Level, auf dem wir rumschweben. Ich studiere eine Geisteswissenschaft. Das heißt, ich bin auch so von meiner Denke her Geisteswissenschaftler. Das heißt, wenn ich an Veränderung und Revolution und sowas denke, dann denke ich natürlich erstmal auf der politischen und gesellschaftspolitischen Ebene. Das heißt, meine Forderung konkret wäre, dass die Veränderungen so passieren, dass es nicht nötig wird, dass sich alle User emanzipieren müssen.
Na Moment, wenn du Geisteswissenschaftler bist, dann kennst du dich doch mit der Aufklärung aus.
Richtig. Und ich halte Kant für, ja soll ich jetzt nochmal den Satz drunter beten, mit der selbstverschuldeten Unmündigkeit. Das halte ich für Blödsinn und das halte ich für eine unglaubliche Verkürzung, die überhaupt nicht anerkennt, dass man in eine Welt hineingeboren wird und den Umständen ausgeliefert ist, zu einem gewissen Maß. Und man hat quasi eine gewisse Gestaltungsmacht aus dieser hineingeworfenen, reichen, ich will kurz zum Punkt kommen.
Du sagst also nicht jeder User ist für sich selbst verantwortlich oder kann für sich selbst vollständig verantwortlich sein. Richtig, von den Fähigkeiten her. Was ist deine Schlussfolgerung für die Netzpolitik in Deutschland?
Es muss Leute geben, die im Auftrag derer, die das nicht schaffen werden, z.B. von uns durchschnittlichen Geisteswissenschaftlern, die vielleicht auf einer anderen Ebene Unglaubliches leisten können, z.B. in der Anwendung von Web 2.0 und so weiter, da einfach so zu kämpfen, dass die Forderung, dass jeder ein Kriterium benutzt oder sowas, dass die nicht mehr wichtig wird. Weil wir in einer Welt leben, also das hätte ich gern, weil wir in einer Welt leben können, in der es überflüssig wird, dass wir Kriterium benutzen, in der sozusagen auch Governance und so weiter, in der zum Beispiel Regierungsthemen so abgehandelt und geschlossen sind.
Okay, aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich glaube, das sozusagen ist eine...
Relativ langfristig gedacht.
Relativ langfristig gedacht ist auch, glaube ich, in der Realisierbarkeit kurz nach, ich möchte gern den Goldpot am Ende des Regenbogens. Und wir wollen heute so ein bisschen über die politischen Wirklichkeiten sprechen. Also über das, was heute in der Netzpolitik geschehen soll und vor allen Dingen auch geschehen kann. Wir sind hier gerade bei den öffentlichen Daten eigentlich angekommen. Also wie gesagt, alles, was durch Steuergelder finanziert wurde, soll auch öffentlich gemacht werden im Netz, auch so lesbar, dass man es weiterverarbeitet.
Nicht öffentlich, sondern allgemeinfrei. Also ich darf es auch benutzen. Also nicht nur für mich privat, sondern ich darf auch eine Firma machen, die das auswertet.
Es soll auch von zur Verfügung stehen und es soll auch verarbeitbar sein. Also sowohl juristisch als auch technisch.
Und, Moment, daraus folgt auch nicht patentierbar. Allgemeinfrei und nicht patentierbar. Also im Moment ist es so, dass Unis quasi gemessen werden in ihrer Qualität daran, wie viel Ausgliederungen sie haben und wie viele Patente auf Forschung an dieser Uni erlassen werden. Und das ist eigentlich genau der falsche Weg, denn wir als Steuerzeile finanzieren die Forschung, damit das Wissen gemähert wird, nicht damit mehr Patente entstehen.
Ich würde dazu jetzt gerne Stefan dazunehmen, weil Stefan studiert Informatik und will genau über diese Wissenschaft zum Veröffentlichen reden. Hallo Stefan.
Achso, hallo. Ich bin schon fertig mit meinem Informatikstudium und bin jetzt derzeit am Promovieren. Ah, deswegen.
Haben Sie nicht genötigt, einen Patent zu machen?
Nein, also Gott sei Dank bin ich ja Informatiker und zum Glück, da bin ich auch sehr, sehr froh drüber, gibt es ja keine Zost-Fair-Patenten. Wo ich auch, ja, wo ich selber sehr glücklich bin. Aber ich bin ja selber halt Autor auch von Veröffentlichungen und muss jetzt also zumindest mal sagen, die Veröffentlichungen, die so im Bereich Informatik stattfinden, die sind eigentlich fast alle zugänglich. Also meine sind zum Beispiel auch auf meiner Homepage drauf. Und eigentlich schicken die Autoren sowas auch immer zu, wenn man sich natürlich auch immer liest, wenn einer das Zeug halt liest. Prinzipiell finde ich eigentlich die Herangehensweise ganz richtig. Und eigentlich gibt es einen Kreditpunkt, den ich eigentlich auch relativ stichfest finde. Also was zum Beispiel gegen diese allgemeine Veröffentlichung im Internet spricht, da hat mich nämlich mal einer dann drauf angesprochen und der hat gesagt, das Problem ist, dass dieser Deal zwischen Europa, USA und Japan und Australien relativ gut funktioniert. Aber er sagt, ein relativ großes Problem ist, dass zum Beispiel gerade China sehr, sehr viele wissenschaftliche Veröffentlichungen dann daraus abruft. Aber selber seine eigenen Forschungsergebnisse nur sehr, sehr spärlich wiederum der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung stellt. Also dass die sich diesen Deal dann in gewisser Weise entziehen.
Das ist ein Gerücht, das stimmt nicht.
Das stimmt nicht?
Nee. Also das mag vielleicht in manchen Bereichen zu sein, aber die, die ich kenne, ist nicht so. Im Gegenteil. Also gerade bei der Kryptographie ist es so, dass einige der wichtigsten Ergebnisse in den letzten Jahren von chinesischen Forschern kommen. Und im Übrigen selbst, wenn es so wäre, entweder es geht uns um die Forschung oder es geht uns nicht um die Forschung. Und wenn es um die Forschung geht, dann veröffentlichen wir die Sachen. Das ist für uns gut und wenn es für andere gut ist, naja. Na und?
Naja, außerdem muss man auch mit einem guten Beispiel vorangehen. Du kannst ja nicht nur, weil es ein schlechtes Beispiel in der Welt gibt, dann alle anderen zurückhalten. Also von daher.
Das ist auch eine Sache, die sich von selbst reguliert. Wenn du was erfindest und du machst ein Paper zu und die Chinesen klauen das und machen auch was damit, dann bist du immer noch vorne auf deinem Fachbereich. Das heißt, du hast den Wegweiser gesteckt, wo es lang geht. Und du bist der, der vorne ist in der Forschung. Du hast immer noch einen Vorteil, selbst wenn sie es geklaut haben.
Wenn ich die Sachen veröffentliche, also ich bin ja derzeit nicht einer kommerziellen Umsetzung interessiert. Wenn ich es veröffentliche, freue ich mich ja gerade, wenn Leute darauf aufbauen. Dafür mache ich auch gerade die Forschung. Das war, wie gesagt, ein Kritikpunkt, der da mal angebracht wurde. Wo ich mal wissen wollte, wie da eigentlich der weitere Stand ist, weil darüber habe ich bisher nur mit einer einzigen Person geredet. Deswegen fand ich den mal ganz stichhaltig.
Es gibt noch einen Punkt, also das mit der auf der eigenen Homepage veröffentlichen, ist ein guter erster Anfang, aber ich war auch mal an der Uni, meine Homepage ist inzwischen weg. Und so wird dir das auch gehen. Wenn du die Uni verlässt, irgendwann ist deine Homepage weg und dann hast du vielleicht ein Backup von deinem Paper oder vielleicht auch nicht. Also wir sagen, nicht nur das soll allgemeinfrei sein, sondern der Staat soll es ins Internet stellen und soll dafür sorgen, dass es verfügbar bleibt.
Ja, dass das nicht eigentlich schon gewährleistet. Na gut, im Internet nicht, eigentlich ist es durch die Bibliothek.
Genau, Bibliotheken sind schön und gut, aber im Moment ist es so, dass du mit Steuergeldern finanziert, dein Paper forschst, und dann gibst du das einem Verlag und der publiziert das und dann kaufen alle anderen Unis das von dem Verlag. Und die Leistung ist aber von dir gekommen, und die habe ich schon bezahlt als Steuerzahler. Und ich zahle jetzt also zweimal dafür. Erstens einmal an dich, damit du das forschst, was gut ist, und einmal an die Verlage, und das pro Uni. Und das kostet einen Schweine Geld.
Also dem Problem bin ich ja vollkommen bewusst. Das ist ja wie gesagt, und deswegen stelle ich das auch öffentlich online, beziehungsweise gebe ich auch, also ich kann auch davon reden, es ist eigentlich gang und gäbe auch Paper so weiter auszuteilen, wenn man die als PDFs hat und so. Ein sehr großer Teil sind ja auch schon zugänglich durch die digitalen Bibliotheken von der ACM und von der AIWI, aber da zahlen die hochschon, so wie ich weiß, auch sehr, sehr viel Geld für, um diese Zugänge zu haben. Also die sind auch nicht gerade billig.
Das ist nicht billig, genau.
Was mich jetzt auch noch interessieren würde, ist, es gibt jetzt auch so Forschung, die wird dann teilweise aus der Industrie finanziert. Was soll denn damit geschehen? Also Drittmittel-Forschung heißt das dann, glaube ich.
Ja, da hatte ich auch mal eine Diskussion gehabt. Da hatten wir mal einen Ringverlesungskurs, nämlich über Patente gehabt. Wie gesagt, zum Glück sind wir in der Informatik da nicht ganz so stark von betroffen. Aber da habe ich den Dozenten mal genau die gleiche Frage gestellt. Da habe ich den aber auch mal genau, exakt nämlich diese Frage gestellt. Da habe ich gesagt, also im Endeffekt, ich zahle ja dann für dieses Forschungsprojekt, ich zahle für den Anteil der Hochschule, die das macht. Warum soll dann das, was da rauskommt, dieses Patent halt nicht allgemein zur Verfügung stehen für alle anderen? Weil alle haben ja schon dafür gezahlt. Da ist dann der Dozent, der von einem großen internationalen Maschinenbauer kommt, nicht wirklich darauf eingelangen. Also ich habe da eigentlich genau die gleiche Meinung. Also wenn man da sagt, da wurde halt dann irgendwas erforscht und da halt Steuermittel drin sind, dann hat man es ja schon bereits bezahlt.
Also eine Sache kann man drüber nachdenken. Also man könnte ja sagen, Patente sind nicht generell schlecht, aber unser Land patentiert es, damit quasi andere Länder Lizenzgebühren zahlen müssen, wenn sie unsere Forschung gebrauchen. Also da könnte man von mir aus drüber reden. Aber ich als Steuerzahler in dem Land, der das finanziert habe, sehe nicht einen, nochmal Lizenzgebühren zahlen zu müssen.
Obwohl wir dann wieder bei der gleichen Frage eigentlich fast wären wie bei der Forschung. Also warum sollte dann mit einer Forschung eine Abschottung der einzelnen Länder möglich sein, bei den Patenten eine Abschottung der einzelnen Länder möglich sein, aber nicht bei der Forschung?
Na, weil einen langen Weg geht man immer in einzelnen Schritten. Und wir können jetzt hier nicht alles auf einmal umwerfen. Aber langfristig bin ich persönlich auch der Meinung, dass wir Patente ganz abschaffen sollten.
Also im Endeffekt bin ich auch gegen Patente, weil das greift zwar ein bisschen weit, aber ich glaube zum Beispiel, das geht zwar auch von der Netzpolitik weg, aber eine Menge Bereiche, wo es Probleme gibt, zum Beispiel insbesondere der Gesundheitsbereich, da sind Pharma-Patente glaube ich ein Teil des Problems, dass Medikamentenpreise dann auch so hoch sind. Da muss man natürlich gucken, wie man das anders schützen könnte. Ja, das ist ein Teil des Problems, würde ich sagen. Teil. Nicht das komplette Problem.
Dann machen wir mal eine eigene Sendung zu.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also mit den Patenten kommen wir dann auch nicht weit. Das ist ganz schön krass, so ein paar Thesen hier aufzustellen. Dann schaffen wir es weiter. Weil, Stefan, letzte Frage ist zu sagen, ich glaube, dass diese ganze Diskussion um die Patenten also tatsächlich realpolitisch spannend ist, weil ich glaube, dass viel bei der Uni ja mittlerweile auch finanziert wird über Drittmittel quasi und wenn man sagt, es gibt gar keine Patente mehr, zumindest in unserem Land nicht, dann gehen die halt woanders hin oder das Geld bricht weg und da müsste man echt nochmal sagen, also wahrscheinlich den ganzen Bildungsapparat dann irgendwie einmal umbauen.
Das stimmt halt gerade nicht.
Das glaube ich aber zum sehr, sehr großen Teil nicht. Also wie gesagt, gerade ich so als Informatiker und im Softwarebereich, da gibt es nun in Europa keine Patente. Also wurde alles über das Urheberrecht gemacht und die Wirtschaft funktioniert da eigentlich auch sehr, sehr gut und insbesondere gibt es da einem auch, wenn man jetzt sich selbstständig macht mit einer Idee, einen sehr, sehr großen Druck, dass man sich auf nicht einen bestimmten technischen Stand ausruhen kann, weil halt solange ich 25 Jahre mehr Patentgebühren bezahle, wächst da eh keiner mehr nach, sondern man ist halt dann ständig auch getrieben von dem Punkt, wo man halt gerade ist, auch noch weiter zu machen und halt irgendwie den Kunden noch weiter zu überzeugen oder die Abnehmer der eigenen Software. Also ich würde sagen, Patente, also...
Machen wir mal eine eigene Sendung für. Das ist ein größeres Thema.
Stefan, aber vielen Dank auf jeden Fall. Bis dahin, tschüss. So, ihr könnt weiterhin anrufen, 0331 70 97 110 und wir sind jetzt bei den Patenten angekommen. Was kommt als nächstes?
Ja, wir haben noch 19. Nein, also die nächste These geht um private Daten und da geht es darum, dass man dem Staat eine Datensparsamkeitsregelung auferlegt und natürlich auch den Firmen. Ja, für die Firmen haben wir dann ein Konzept namens Datenbrief, das haben wir schon an anderer Stelle erklärt, wie das funktionieren soll. Aber wir möchten gerne dafür sorgen, dass sowohl der Staat als auch Firmen keinen Grund haben, Daten über mich zu sammeln, die sie nicht brauchen und wenn sie sie haben, möchten wir aktiv Anreiz schaffen, dass die Daten nicht gespeichert werden.
Definiere Daten, die sie nicht brauchen. Also, wie unterscheiden die sich von Daten, die sie brauchen?
Na, also ein Beispiel dafür wäre, dass wir einen Personalausweis haben. Das sind jetzt nicht nur Daten, aber so als anschauliches Beispiel. Wir haben einen Personalausweis, die Briten haben keinen, wusstest du das?
Äh, ja, das ist das...
Die Amerikaner haben auch keinen.
Ich hab damals dort gemerkt, dass da sehr viel Aufregung war, als sie einen einführen wollten.
Genau, die wollen seit 30 Jahren einen einführen und sie brauchen ihn einfach bis heute nicht.
Und das Schöne ist ja, als Deutscher denkt man so, der Personalausweis gab es schon immer, wird schon irgendwie seine Berechtigung haben. Warum brauchen wir denn keinen Personalausweis?
Weißt du eigentlich, warum wir keinen Fingerabdruck im Personalausweis haben? Wir hatten mal einen bei den Nazis und die Alliäten haben das abgeschafft, weil sie gesagt haben, das ist unwürdig.
Oh, und jetzt haben wir wieder einen, toll, ne?
Aber trotzdem, warum braucht es keinen Personalausweis?
Weil du kannst auch ohne ihn überleben und es ist nicht so, dass die da weniger Strafverfolgung hätten oder mehr Kriminalität. Oder dass da die Banken weniger Schrottanleihen kaufen. Ich meine, die ganzen Probleme, mit denen wir tatsächlich zu kämpfen haben, die haben alle wenig damit zu tun, ob ich einen Personalausweis habe oder nicht.
Aber andererseits sozusagen ist, macht der Personalausweis auch viele Dinge einfacher. Also wenn ich irgendwo nachweisen will, ich bin es, kann ich einfach vorzeigen, das glaubt mir auch jeder. Wie soll das denn dann, wenn es keinen Personalausweis gibt, geklärt werden? Okay, da verstehe ich jetzt aber den Unterschied nicht. Also warum sozusagen...
Ja warum haben wir denn einen Personalausweis und einen Pass?
Ist doch blöd, oder?
Weil der Personalausweis so klein praktisch zum Rumtragen ist und beim Pass kann man reinstempeln.
Und die Gesundheitskarte, wie ist der mit der Gesundheitskarte? Nee, warum haben wir denn Gesundheitskarten? Ich meine, es gibt so viele Beispiele, die vielleicht alle nicht offensichtlich sind. Oder die Mautdaten. Warum müssen wir denn Mautdaten aufheben von LKWs, die irgendwo lang fahren? Brauchen wir das?
Nee.
Die fallen am Bahn...
Verkehrsflusskontrolle.
Ja, Bullshit, wenn ich das mal sagen darf. Nein, wir sammeln an allen Orten und älten irgendwelche Daten, die wir nicht wirklich brauchen, weil es nämlich einfacher ist, Daten zu sammeln, als vorher darüber nachzudenken, ob man sie eigentlich braucht oder nicht.
Und das soll in Zukunft dann geschehen?
In Zukunft soll es ein richtiges Gebot der Datensparsamkeit geben, dass der Staat begründen muss, und zwar nicht nur Larifari, ja, das ist besser für die Strafverfolgung, sondern tatsächlich handfest begründen, und zwar mit vorliegenden Zahlen und Untersuchungen, dass dieses Datum tatsächlich nützlich ist und hilft. Und dann muss immer noch abgewogen werden, ob der Schaden, der entsteht, dadurch dass es gesammelt wird, den Nutzen nicht übersteigt. Und erst dann darf das Datum gesammelt werden. Wir möchten gerne eine Bürokratie schaffen, an der Stelle, die ist aufwendig und widerlich und eklig macht, mehr Daten zu speichern, als du brauchst.
Es ist derzeit ein Problem, dass es billiger ist, die Daten einfach zu sammeln, als Überlegungen anzustellen, wozu brauche ich die eigentlich.
Das ist auch eins der Hauptprobleme. Du hörst doch immer, dass die Leute Probleme haben, Datenbanken zusammenzuführen. Überleg doch mal, was heißt denn das? Die Leute haben Datenbanken, die sie nicht zusammengeführt haben. Das heißt, sie wollen jetzt Verbindungen schaffen, an die sie nicht gedacht haben, als sie die Daten gesammelt haben. Das heißt, sie haben die Daten gesammelt, bevor sie wussten, dass sie sie dafür brauchen. Vielleicht brauchen sie sie für was anderes. In manchen Fällen mag das stimmen. In vielen Fällen heißt es aber einfach, wir haben die Daten, dann sammeln wir sie halt.
Und so läuft das. André findet das auch nicht toll, er hat hier angerufen.
Hallo André, dann erzähl mal.
Hallo Fritz Team, hallo Fefe, hallo Gast, den ich jetzt gerade nicht mehr so in Erinnerung habe. Es geht mir ganz vor allem darum, wenn der Staat schon so viel Daten hat, und der hat ja ganz verdammt viele Daten über mich, warum muss ich dann jedes Mal, wenn ich irgendwas beantrage, ganz viel in irgendwelche Papierbögen einfüllen? Und selbst wenn ich das online mache, muss ich ganz viel selber ausfüllen. Und es geht ja noch weiter. Warum muss ich, wenn ich sowas beantrage, dann noch meinen Eltern, zum Beispiel beim Unterhalt, was in die Hand geben, was die denn wiederum deren Chef in die Hand geben, was der dann ausfüllen muss? Warum kann ich wenigstens einen Nutzen draus gezogen werden? Also das ist so eine Sache, die ich mir einfach nicht kommt.
Aber, aber, das ist gut so. Das ist eine These, die ich seit einigen Jahren äußere. Unser bester Schutz vor dem Unterdrückungsstaat ist die Inkompetenz der Unterdrücker.
Kann man öfter mal auf deinem Blog lesen, ja. Aber ich möchte trotzdem irgendwo an der Stelle, ich meine, Sie haben doch so viele Verbindungen. Es muss doch aber möglich sein, dann für uns einen Nutzen rauszuziehen. Also, das, das, das will mir nicht in den Kopf. Das kann mir auch nicht einfach so abtun, weil Sie doof sind. Es, es, ich finde, es sollte auch eine These sein, dass ja eben, dass aus diesen ganzen Geschichten, die der Staat ohnehin erhoben hat, ein Nutzen für den Bürger gezogen werden muss. Und zwar ein fühlbarer. Ich meine, man kann ja mit dem dem ja sehres Bullshit-Bingo weitermachen und kann sagen, macht doch mal irgendwelche, irgendwelche Thesen, die sagen, es muss ein fühlbarer Nutzen für den Bürger dabei herauskommen.
Das passiert aber nicht. Also ich meine, wir versuchen jetzt mal so eine These zu formulieren.
Ich möchte kurz eine Zwischenfrage stellen. Und zwar ist es, plädierst du dafür, das was Fefe gerade gesagt hat, also Daten dürfen nur dann gesammelt werden, wenn sie einen praktischen Nutzen haben? Oder plädierst du dafür, die sollen ruhig Daten sammeln, aber dann sollen sie wenigstens was ordentliches draus bauen?
Nein, ich bin eigentlich sogar für beides. Ich meine, der Staat braucht ja die Daten.
Das geht nicht. Weil es sich ausschließt. Entweder sagst du so sparsam wie möglich.
Wir haben sogar noch eine These in die Gegenrichtung.
Ja, aber der Staat braucht doch einige Daten bei mich. Der Staat muss doch meinetwegen wissen, ja, keine Ahnung, ich bin so und so alt, meine Eltern sind die und die. Das muss er wissen.
Du bist dafür, dass alle diese Daten zusammengeführt werden, was ja eigentlich gerade nicht passieren soll, wie wir heute hier schon gehört haben, weil es praktischer ist.
Ich bin dafür, dass, wenn die schon zusammengeführt werden und der Staat uns das irgendwie einrichtet...
Nee, das passiert ja gerade nicht. Das ist ja dein Kritikpunkt, dass es nicht passiert.
Dann sollen sie es vielleicht auch zu unserem Guten tun.
Ja, guck mal, das Problem ist, wenn du so eine Regelung hast, dann hast du nämlich die Schranke dafür, Daten zu heben auf es ist nützlich gelegt. Und dann werden sie alles speichern. Ja, ich sag mal ein Beispiel. Ich fände es persönlich sehr nützlich, wenn ich keine Steuererklärung abgeben müsste, denn alle Zahlungen, die ich so mache, gehen über irgendwelche Karten oder Konten. Und da hat der Staat E-Interfaces, um einsehen zu können. Und eigentlich kann der Staat auch meine Steuererklärung für mich machen. Ja, das könnte man argumentieren. Das würde mir echt Stress sparen. Aber wollen wir das? Nein, wollen wir nicht.
Ja, könnte du noch dein Auto überwachen, weil dann hast du gleich ein Fahrtbuch.
Genau, wir können auch Maut, genau. Wir machen einfach Maut, indem wir GPS einbauen in alle Autos. Eine tolle Idee, haben die Niederländer auch gemacht. Wollen wir aber nicht.
Es gibt ja auch trotzdem viel banalere Beispiele, wo es sinnvoll wäre. Ich habe Bekannte, die wollten heiraten. Du kannst dir gar nicht vorstellen, was das für ein Stress ist, zwischen den Behörden, bis du alle Papiere zusammen hast, damit die Leute heiraten können. Obwohl, vom Prinzip, das alles Behörden sind, die eigentlich miteinander zu tun haben. Von der Meldebehörde und dem Standesamt usw. Das liegt ja jetzt nicht so weit auseinander.
Du musst an die Arbeitsplätze denken, wie das schafft.
Das ist vielleicht das, was man sich fragen würde. Was machst du mit der vielen Zeit, die du auf einmal gewinnst? Und was machst du mit den vielen Beamten, die auf einmal überflüssig werden? Und mit dem ganzen Apparat. Und das ist ja vom Prinzip das, was wir bei jeder Behörde immer wieder sehen, ist, dass jede Behörde nur versucht, eigentlich ihre Prozesse möglichst so komplex zu halten, damit eben keine Macht abgebaut wird, keine Arbeitsplätze abgebaut werden.
Aber ich verstehe, ist das doch eine gute Idee, weil dann jeder genau nur die Daten verarbeitet, die er selber braucht, und es gibt keine Zentralisierung.
Genau, das wollen wir auch so. Das ist übrigens derselbe Gedanke, der unserem Staat zugrunde legt, wenn wir mal drüber nachdenken. Wir haben einen föderalen Staat, und wir haben diverse Checks und Balances, die darauf ausgelegt sind, dass kein einzelner Triebtäter loslaufen kann. Wenn wir einen noch so verrückten Kanzler haben, der kann nicht einfach irgendwelche Gesetze machen, sondern da muss noch der Bundesrat zustimmen, und der Bundespräsident muss es unterschreiben, und das Verfassungsgericht muss der Meinung sein, das ist verfassungsgerecht. Diese Art von Verteilung ist die Grundidee von eigentlich allen machthabenden demokratischen Strukturen, und das sollen wir auch für Daten haben.
Ich fasse mal zusammen, André hätte es gerne ein bisschen bequemer als dafür auch sozusagen bereit, das ein bisschen aufzugeben mit den Datensammeln, aber ihr sagt, nee, nur so wenig Daten wie möglich, und vorher soll gewusst werden, dafür nehmen wir auch in Kauf, dass es sozusagen genauso unbequem ist wie jetzt, bzw. vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen aufwendiger wird. Weil wir gerade, also irgendwie die Zeit läuft uns jetzt schon davon, und wir sind noch nicht mal bei These 6 oder so, weil wir aber gerade über den Personalausweis gesprochen haben, würde ich gerne den Patrick nochmal dazuholen, der Erfahrungen damit hat, steht hier. Patrick, hallo. Was willst du uns über den Personalausweis erzählen?
Ja, also ich bin einfach nur, also ich hab mir einen Bart wachsen lassen.
Ein was? Ein Bart?
Einen Bart wachsen lassen, ja.
Ein Bart?
Ja, ich hatte vorher keine Gesichtbehauung und dann bin ich mit Gesichtbehauung über die Grenze gefahren. Nach Tschengen.
Das macht man auch nicht.
So, dann hab ich Gesichtbehauung gehabt und dann waren die deutschen Fälle und haben gesagt, das sind sie ja nicht. Im Personal ausweist. So, ich so, ja klar bin ich das. Und dann meinte der tschechische Grenzbeamte, der konnte dann halt auch tschechisch und der hat dann gemeint, ja, da müssen sie jetzt rasieren. Und hat das aber erschärft.
Wir haben mal so einen Scherz intern gehabt im CCC. Wir haben gesagt, wir lassen uns einen Biometrie-Bard wachsen.
Ja, genau.
Also du hast jetzt einen Biometrie-Bard.
Also ich hatte einen Bart, ja, und damit hätten die mich, die deutschen Kölner eigentlich, niemals über die Grenze laufen lassen. So, und die zweite Sache ist halt die. Mein Bruder, der hat halt diesen Bio-Pastbeamten tragen müssen, weil er nach Amerika gefahren ist. Und die waren halt mit dem Biometriebild nicht zufrieden. Und dann haben die das halt so lange gedreht. Also erstmal ist er halt zum Fotografen hin. Er hat gesagt, ja, das Bild ist nicht okay. Dann haben die noch ein Bild gemacht und dann war es dem Fotografen egal.
Das wurde dann gefotoshoppt, ja, das bei unseren Pässen genau so.
Genau, dann wurde das gefotoshoppt. Und dann war das okay und dann ist das Fotografen-Bild in den Pass.
Es gibt Leute, die sind einfach nicht kompatibel.
Das ist doch dann wieder ein super Argument für Fingerabdrücke, Wien-Muster, Wien-Erkennung.
Das ist ein Argument dafür, dass du dieses Bild nicht brauchst. Denn wenn du es bräuchtest, wärst du an der Stelle mit Photoshop nicht weitergekommen. Hier greift also unsere These private Daten schützen. Das sind Daten, die sie nicht brauchen. Datensparsamkeit sagt, dürfen sie nicht erheben. Fertig. Genau das meinen wir damit. Genau. Wir sind uns alle einig. Was für eine langweilige Sendung. Nimm noch mal ein paar Querulanten rein hier.
Alles klar, gut.
Danke Patrick.
Das wird eine super Geschichte. Die wird bestimmt in die Annalen eingehen. Und, ähm, ja, Querulanten? Also du meinst Leute, die nicht deiner Meinung sind?
Äh, na, so weit würde ich jetzt nicht gehen.
Na gut, wenn ihr euch jetzt auf irgendeine Art und Weise angesprochen fühlt, gilt folgendes.
Eure Meinung jetzt anrufen.
Leute, jetzt kommen die Thesen.
Wenn das verdammte rote Licht an ist, ist das Mikrofon offen.
Ja, na und?
Ist das jetzt geheim gewesen oder was? Weiß ich ja nicht.
Aber ihr tut immer so. Nein, nein, nein. Wir sind eine anonyme Aussage. Hör mal, das ist doch hier Teil unseres Jobs, oder? So ein bisschen Mysterie aufzubauen. Ah, verstehe.
Okay, jetzt ist der Jochen da. Jochen fährt das unreglementierte Internet.
Bist du ein Querulant, Jochen?
Guten Morgen. Ja, Querulant, ja. Wenn es nach der Gesetzgebung geht, dann bin ich ja wohl schon noch irgendwo ein Querulant. Denn Netzneutralität finde ich doch schon irgendwie ein wichtiges Argument. Ja, geht doch nicht an, dass man zum Beispiel... Zum Beispiel Google, das habe ich gerade eben schon der Redaktion gesagt. Man findet doch auf Google gar keinen Youporn mehr. Wie kommt denn das? Das ist doch auch eine Art von Reglementierung. Ja, jetzt nur mal ein blödes Beispiel.
Das ist der Jugendschutz. Das ist noch ein ganz anderes Ding. Das ist in der Tat eine These, die wir noch nicht erwähnt haben.
Ja gut, Jugendschutz hin oder her. Das mit den Netzsperren, von wegen Mrs. von der Leyen und ihre Zensosler-Sachen und all hin und her. Nur dadurch, dass ich das verschwinden lasse, durch welche Methode jetzt auch immer, durch Proxy-Server oder dass ich ein DNS-Sperre dahinter herhauere oder was auch immer, dadurch verschwinden die Sachen doch nicht aus der Welt.
Du, das ist eine Einstellung bei Google. Das kannst du auch einschalten und dann kriegst du auch wieder Porn.
Na gut, das wusste ich nicht.
Wenn es um Porn geht, helfen wir gerne.
Na ja, sehr schön. Ich finde es gut, dass wir mir auch helfen konnten. Chaosradio, die Service-Sendung. Viel Spaß dabei. Und wir haben jetzt noch den Thomas, der etwas noch zum Thema Software zu sagen hat.
Ich möchte eigentlich direkt zum Punkt kommen.
Eine gute Idee. Passiert viel zu selten. Vor allem Politiker machen das selten.
Könnt ihr vom CCC nicht mal eine Software entwickeln, mit der man Informationen zu politischen Problemen irgendwie sammeln kann?
Ich glaube, es gibt die Software, die heißt Wiki.
Ja, es gibt erstens Wikipedia. Da stehen auch ganz viele echt unangenehme Details zu Politikern. Und wenn sie da noch nicht stehen, dann tragt ihr sie ein. Und dann gibt es Abgeordnetenwatch. Da stehen auch ganz viele echt peinliche Sachen. Das Hauptproblem ist nicht die Software. Die Software gibt es. Du kannst über Wikipedia alles eintragen, wenn du möchtest. Oder kannst du auch ein eigenes Wiki machen.
Du kannst die Information zwar sammeln, aber du kannst sie schlecht darstellen. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du ein Softwareprojekt hast und das Ding hat Probleme, also Bugs oder so was, dann trägst du das ja nicht in einem Wiki ein, sondern in einem Bug Tracker.
Also du willst Bugs von Politikern sammeln?
Nicht von Politikern, sondern vom politischen System.
Und von Gesetzen, von Gesetzentwürfen. Das wäre doch mal geil. Ein Bug Tracker für Gesetzentwürfe, wollen wir das nicht mal machen? Das ist ein cooler Punkt, den notieren wir mal.
Aber sag doch mal kurz für die Leute, die nicht wissen, was ein Bug Tracker ist.
Es ist ein Software-System, wo man konkrete Informationen über Probleme in Systemen an zentraler Stelle sammeln kann.
Und das zeigt dann automatisiert auch an, dass hier Komponente blabla hat Probleme mit Komponente blabla.
Ja genau, und man kann die auch halt filtern nach Priorität und so weiter. Und man kann halt Analyse an zentraler Stelle sammeln.
Das könnte man dann gleich noch in Walomaten draufsetzen.
Ich weiß nicht, aber...
Nee, eigentlich kannst du Gesetze automatisiert durchfallen lassen, wenn sie mehr als einen Bugs haben.
Also jetzt mal ernsthaft, also ihr vom CCC habt ja eine Menge politische Probleme auf dem Radar. Aber es gibt ja noch eine ganze Menge andere politische Probleme, zum Beispiel Atomkraft oder Bürgerrechte, Frauenrechte und so weiter. Ich meine, die Informationen dazu sind über Tausende von Webseiten und Blogs verstreut. Und wenn man die wirklich mal versucht zu sammeln, dann wird man wahnsinnig, weil das so verstreut ist. Das ist unglaublich eigentlich. Und es wäre eigentlich mal schön, wenn man das an einer Zentralstelle so sammeln könnte.
Vom Prinzip geht das ja Richtung Open Government so, dass du eben die Bürger mit einbeziehen kannst in Entscheidungsprozesse, den Bürgern ermöglicht Feedback zu geben zu bestimmten Dingen. Also die Software dafür existiert in vielen Fällen natürlich noch nicht, aber das ist so, ich sag mal, die Bewegung, die in diese Richtung geht und die eben ermöglichen möchte, dass viel mehr Leute sich an diesen ganzen Prozessen beteiligen. Und das ist natürlich sicherlich sinnvoll.
Von Open Governance möchte ich gar nicht nochmal reden. Es geht eigentlich erstmal nur darum, Informationen überhaupt zu sammeln. Was man damit macht, das ist schon der zweite Schritt.
Du willst eine praktische Lösung, aber der Redakteur hat dich eingetragen, du seist in der Softwarebranche tätig. Warum schreibst du diese Software nicht?
Der hat einen nicht überhört. Sonst würde ich das gerne machen, aber mir fehlt das Geld dazu.
Das Geld, ok. Nein, der ist gilt. Dann gehst du zum CCC und lässt dir das zeigen. Wir haben schöne Hacker-Bases und da hängen Programmierer ab. Dann kann man hingehen und sich das zeigen lassen. Also unabhängig davon, verteilt von Daten wird gern als Nachteil gesehen, aber es ist auch ein Vorteil, weil es nämlich das System weniger angreifbar macht. Wenn du eine zentrale Webseite hast, wo alle Daten sind, dann müssen diese Webseite runterfahren und dann ist deine ganze Bewegung entkernt. Aber wenn die Daten dezentral liegen, dann ist das schwieriger. Deswegen ist auch der CCC eine dezentrale Vereinigung.
Aber schick ist die Idee schon.
Schick ist die Idee schon und ich finde auch, man sollte das tun. Software zum Sammeln und Verteilen von Daten, das ist im Grunde die Haupt- und Kernaufgabe von Informatik und überhaupt von Software.
Thomas hat die Idee gehabt, vielen Dank dafür.
Wie viele Thesen haben wir jetzt noch übrig eigentlich? Na, wir werden sie ja nicht alle verlesen.
Aber wie viele Thesen haben wir noch?
Noch zwei in dem Blog, den wir angefangen haben.
Die skippen wir?
Nee, Moment, ganz kurz sprechen wir die an.
Okay, wir machen jetzt Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr. Gut, danach sprechen wir die an und danach machen wir weiter. Alles klar.
Habt ihr euch auch immer schon mal gefragt, wo mir ihr erstes Video gedreht haben?
Was Apparat und Modeselektor am hackischen Markt treiben?
Oder warum sich Wir-sind-Helden-partout-nicht-auf-ein-Band-Namen einigen konnten? Die Fritz Music Tours.
Auf den Spuren der Berliner Popmusik.
Jetzt auch mit Walking Tour.
Zu Fuß durch Berlins musikalische Mitte.
Immer mittwochs und sonntags.
Und die Bustour gibt's natürlich auch weiterhin.
Immer samstags oder nach Wunschtermin.
Wann genau und wo genau?
FritzD.
Fritz Music Tours Berlin.
Neue Musikgeschichten zu neuer Musikgeschichte.
Zu Fuß, im Bus und an der Rufschrauber-Variante arbeiten wir noch.
Und das hört man. Um kurz nach halb 12. Mit Kaiathan Dürlich.
Deutschland hat einen neuen Bundespräsidenten. Die Bundesversammlung wählte nach über neun Stunden Christian Wulf. Der Kandidat von Union und FDP erreicht im dritten Wahlgang eine Mehrheit von 625 Stimmen. Der Bewerber von SPD und Grünen Gauck bekam etwa 130 Stimmen weniger. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel begrüßte die Wahl von Wulf und erklärte, dass er der richtige Mann für dieses Amt sei. Wulf wird dann morgen in seinem neuen Amt vereidigt. Die EU, bzw. am Freitag vereidigt, Entschuldigung. Die EU will, dass die einzelnen Mitgliedsländer freiwillig ihre Ferienzeiten untereinander abstimmen. Damit will sie verhindern, dass alle Leute zur gleichen Zeit in den Urlaub fahren. Das wiederum wäre gut für den Tourismus. Die Branche beschwert sich außerhalb der Hochsaison über leere Betten. Deutschland reagierte auf den Vorschlag skeptisch. Die einzelnen Bundesländer hätten schließlich jetzt schon zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten Ferien. Hurricane Alex behindert die Ölbekämpfung im Golf von Mexiko. Wegen meterhoher Wellen mussten die Rettungsschiffe den Hafen anlaufen. Das Abschöpfen und Abfackeln des Ölteppichs kam zum Stillstand. Die US-Regierung hat sich mittlerweile entschlossen, ausländische Hilfsangebote für die Ölbekämpfung anzunehmen. Es handelt sich um 22 Angebote aus 12 Ländern. Deutschland ist bereit, unter anderem Barrieren zum Ölaufsaugen und technisches Personal zur Verfügung zu stellen. Start! Beim Tennis-Grosslamp-Turnier in Wimbledon ist Titelverteidiger Roger Federer im Viertelfinale überraschend ausgeschieden. Der sechsmalige Wimbledon-Sieger unterlag dem Tschechen Tomas Berdig in vier Sätzen und erreichte damit erstmals seit 2002 nicht in der Runde die letzten acht. Wittenberge und Angermünde 17 Grad haben wir jetzt die aktuellen Temperaturen Frankfurt, Neuropie 19, Potsdam und Cottbus 21 und Berlin zwischen 18 und 22 Grad. Heute Nacht sind hier und da noch ein paar Wolgen unterwegs, aber es bleibt meistens trocken. Die Temperaturen gehen heute bis auf 11 Grad runter. Morgen wird es wieder ziemlich schön, viel Sonne und wieder sehr, sehr heiß draußen mit bis zu 30 Grad. Vorsicht auf der AC nördlicher Berliner Ringrichtung 3K-Felan. Zwischen Weißensee und dem Reich Pankow steht im Baustellenbereich ein kaputtes Auto. In der Gegenrichtung ist zwischen Kreuz Oranienburg und Birkenwerder die linke Spur dicht. A12 Berlin Richtung Frankfurt Oder zwischen Mürose und Frankfurt Oder. West, da gibt es Gefahr durch ein unbeleuchtetes Fahrzeug. Auf der rechten Spur da wird er also ganz besonders vorsichtig fahren. A20 Kreuz Uckermark Richtung Rostock zwischen Bremslauer Ost und Pasewalk Süd. Wir sind in beiden Richtungen Tiere auf der Fahrbahn unterwegs. Und das besonders in der Höhe Parkplatz Klokko Ost. Und das war's. Und wie sagt man das jetzt richtig? Ich kann das. Wenn man das dann liest... Grenzlem. Grenzlem ist das peinlich. Gott, ist das peinlich. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Wenn im Radio 103, 1, dann Fritz in der Trignitz.
Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch hier im Chaosradio in Blue Moon und es geht heute um Thesen zur Netzpolitik, weil der Herr de Maizière ja in der letzten Woche 14 davon an den Start gebracht haben. Fefe vom Chaos Computer Club und Daniel meinen, das ist irgendwie nicht so golden und von den 14 kann man genau keine verwenden.
Wir müssen mindestens 15 machen, ist doch völlig klar. Mindestens.
Und deswegen haben sie selber welche mitgebracht. Wir hatten schon, dass Daten geschützt werden sollen, dass öffentliche Daten an den Start kommen sollen, dass jeder User einen Internetanschluss haben soll. Wir haben jetzt noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit. Es gibt eigentlich mehr Thesen, als ich vermute, wie wir umbringen. Kurz zu dem Blog, wo wir jetzt gerade sind.
Unterbringen.
Mit den öffentlichen Daten.
Also, vom Prinzip, wenn wir schon dabei sind, alle möglichen Dinge zu schützen, dann muss auch, und das ist sicherlich ein ganz wichtiger Bestandteil, müssen Publikationen im Internet auch geschützt werden können. Sodass eben so etwas wie Zensur oder auch das Ansicht bringen von unbequemen Wahrheiten über unser Kommunikationsmedium Nummer eins, dass das eben auch geschützt wird. Und das ist etwas, was in Deutschland zum Beispiel auch fehlt. Also es gibt keinen Schutz für sogenannte Whistleblower hier, der im Gesetz verankert wäre. Es gibt zwar umgekehrt den Schutz für Journalisten und die Möglichkeit, dass Journalisten ihre Quellen schützen können und dann eben dazu was publizieren. Aber es gibt keinen Schutz gesetzlich verankert für die Menschen, die eben etwas ans Licht bringen können. Das knüpft ja auch ein bisschen an das, was der Anrufer eben, ich habe den Namen vergessen, gesagt hatte, nämlich dass wir die Möglichkeit haben müssen, Bugs in der Gesellschaft zu tracken oder gewisse Missstände aufzudecken. Das ist was, was wir uns sicherlich auch wünschen würden für die netzpolitische Seite hier.
Das heißt, es geht jetzt aber darum, dass die Leute geschützt werden, die diese Informationen ins Netz bringen, nicht die Informationen im Netz selber.
Also stell dir vor, du bist oberst klein und du hast gerade...
Nein, das ist nicht klar. Es hört sich nur am Anfang so an, als ob sozusagen jede Information, die einmal im Netz gelandet ist, dann auch dort bleiben darf.
Das hängt natürlich auch zusammen.
Hängt schon so miteinander.
Ja, das hängt aber auch relativ eng miteinander zusammen. Also es bringt dir auch nichts, wenn du nur den Menschen schützen kannst, aber niemand kann das im Internet publizieren, weil die Publikation irgendwie zensiert wird. Das sind zwei Punkte, die relativ eng miteinander verknüpft sind.
Also finde ich auch noch ein Problemfeld, dass man dann sagen kann, ja gut, aber ich möchte vielleicht Daten, die über mich ins Netz kommen, dann doch wieder löschen. Dann ist die Frage wohl, verläuft die Grenze. Aber das führt zu weit. Wir haben noch ganz viele andere Thesen.
Relativ eng damit zusammenhängt natürlich, und das ist eigentlich ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, das Recht auf Anonymität. Das hat auch in täglichen Alltag eigentlich jeder. Das heißt, ich kann meine Meinung kundtun. Ich kann mich mit Leuten austauschen, ohne dass ich diesen Leuten meinen Namen verraten muss, ohne dass es einen Provider gibt, der mir diesen Austausch ermöglicht und der dazu Verkehrsdaten von mir vorhält. Und genau das muss eigentlich auch für das Internet gelten. Gerade noch mehr als für jedes andere Medium, weil das Internet eben auch global ermöglicht, dass Menschen sich untereinander austauschen und die demokratischen Prozesse darüber sehr stark gefördert werden. Das heißt, zum einen muss ein Recht auf Anonymität verankert werden und zum anderen muss auch verankert werden, dass eben Leute, die Anonymitätsdienste, wie das mit dem Tornetzwerk zum Beispiel ja gegeben ist, anbieten, dass diese Leute auch vor Repressalien durch den Staat geschützt werden.
Definiere mal Repressalien. Das finde ich bei dem Tornetzwerk halt immer spannend.
Eine Hausdurchsuchung war irgendwie das größte Problem. Wenn du eine Tor-Exit-Note betreibst, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit recht hoch im Moment in Deutschland, dass du eines Tages Besuch von der Polizei erhältst und die bei dir alles, was irgendwie entfernt nach Computern aussieht, raustragen.
Was vom Prinzip ja schon zeigt, wie wenig überhaupt dieses ganze Vorgehen angepasste ist an die Realität. Wenn jemand einen Tor-Note betreibt, dann steht er nicht bei ihm im Wohnzimmer in der Regel und das bringt überhaupt nichts, die Wohnung zu durchsuchen und dort alle Computer mitzunehmen. Also das ist ja schon was, wo die Realität vollkommen entkoppelt ist, irgendwie von dem, wie man von staatlicher Seite davor geht. Aber es geht auch um Dinge wie Haftung oder den Haftungsausschluss eigentlich und eben das Recht, einen Anonymisierungsdienst anzubieten, ohne dafür haftbar zu sein, was mit diesem Anonymisierungsdienst dann im Endeffekt gemacht wird durch Dritte.
Also wir haben ja schon eine Sendung gehabt über WLAN gerade. Und das geht in dieselbe Richtung natürlich. Im Grunde möchten wir nicht, dass Leute belangt werden, weil sie ein offenes WLAN betreiben. Im Gegenteil.
Das sind Helden.
Denn die geben mir Internet, wenn ich verreist bin.
So, weiter geht's.
Genau, so der nächste Komplex, da geht's erstens um den Urheberrechtsschutz. Wir finden nämlich, der ist im Moment viel zu sehr ausgeufert. Im Moment ist es so, dass Leute regelmäßig von Abmahnungen und irgendwelchen Abmahnvereinen belästigt werden. Und dass da Grafen angedroht werden. Und die Musikindustrie da mit Fantasiezahlen operiert. Dass eine existenzielle Bedrohung für die Einzelnen daraus entsteht. Und deswegen finden wir, das muss mal entkernt und saniert werden. Und finden unter anderem, dass da eine Bagatellgrenze eingeführt gehört. Wenn irgendwelche Privatleute eine Urheberrechtsverletzung machen und da keinen kommerziellen Hintergrund hatten und keinen Vorteil daraus gezogen haben, dann wird das nicht verfolgt. Also wir finden, die Zahlen, die da hantiert werden, die sollten mal auf eine faktische Basis gestellt werden. Und wir brauchen sowas wie eine Bagatellgrenze in der Strafverfolgung. Und wir können eigentlich auch noch über ein paar andere Sachen nachdenken, aber das ist eine eigene Sendung.
Es ist ja sogar noch viel schlimmer, das hatten ja einige Publikationen auch auf Wikileaks zum Beispiel gezeigt, dass aus diesem ganzen Urheberrechtsschutz und Abmahnwahn eigentlich ein Geschäftsmodell gemacht wird. Und dass es mittlerweile ja lukrativer zu sein scheint, dass man eben jemanden verfolgt wegen einer Urheberrechtsverletzung als überhaupt das Material, was man verkaufen möchte, eben zu verkaufen. Und das ist ja schon vollkommen pervers an sich.
Genau, also wie viel Urheberrechtsschutz gehört revolutioniert, das muss mal komplett neu gemacht werden.
Ihr nehmt aber sozusagen auch in Kauf, da steckt schon noch so ein bisschen die politische Forderung dahinter, dass Urheberrechtsschutz für Privatleute eigentlich Unsinn ist und ihr denkt, das soll wirklich einfach jeder haben, was er will.
Na ganz so nicht. Aber wenn ich mir einen MP3 runterziehe, dann finde ich, dass der Aufwand für die Verfolgung übersteigt, die den Gewinn für die Gesellschaft durch die Verfolgung um ein Vielfaches. Und da muss irgendwo eine Grenze gezogen werden. Und also wenn jetzt jemand erwischt wird und er hat irgendwie zwei Terabyte MP3s dabei, dann ist die Grenze überschritten. Aber wenn jemand irgendwie mit einem MP3-Player herumläuft und da sind irgendwie ein paar Songs drauf, die er sich kopiert hat, na ja, mein Gott, na und?
Okay, wäre auch spannend, wo man diese Grenze dann zieht.
Genau, das ist eine andere Frage.
Jetzt würde ich gerne noch mal kurz an Andreas dazunehmen, weil das passiert nämlich viel zu selten. Er hat Erfahrung mit Internetzensur im Ausland. Hallo Andreas. Was genau ist dir denn passiert?
Ja, passiert also kurz im Hintergrund. Ich bin Service-Techniker und bin eigentlich 80 Prozent des Jahres nicht in Deutschland, sondern ja, in China, Russland, Japan und solchen Geschichten.
Ganz freie Länder.
Also in China ist zum Beispiel Folgendes passiert, ich sitze ganz normal im Hotel, Internet ist gratis, alles schön und gut. Wikipedia funktioniert einfach nicht. Das hat bis damals nicht funktioniert. Das ist schon ein paar Jahre her. Es kam einfach eine Blank-Seite.
Na ja, das haben wir ja auch manchmal.
Und ich möchte einfach nur so ein bisschen erzählen. Letzte Woche in Italien bin ich auf so eine sogenannte Stoppseite gestoßen. Da kommt dann irgendwie ein offizielles Logo von der Polizei und sagt, hier, da dürfen sie nicht drauf.
Cool, was war denn das, wo du denn hin wolltest?
Eine Pornseite natürlich. Also, ich meine, aber ich dachte, wir haben das nicht. Ich dachte, die EU diskutieren erst darüber und Italien macht das Einzelschaum.
Na ja, Berlusconi halt. Der macht ja noch ganz andere Sachen.
Ja, das ist auch, aber wenigstens konnte er seine Banken retten mit den 500-Euro-Scheinen. Na ja, anyway, und einfach, wie klingt es denn, was ich damit sagen möchte, ist was, was ich nicht verstehe. Ich meine, die Leute, die wissen, dass man diese technischen Sprechen machen kann, schön und gut. Da können sich vielleicht auch einige Leute mit abhalten davon, auf diese Seite zu kommen. Aber ich bin in China auf die Wikipedia-Seite gekommen. Ich bin auch in Italien auf meine Porno-Seite gekommen. Also mit ein bisschen Anleitung und Google-Fragen komme ich da doch immer wieder hin.
Der Punkt ist eigentlich ein anderer. Der Punkt ist, dass es alles näher als es für uns aussieht. Also nicht für uns vom CCC. Wir wissen ja, wie nah das ist. Deswegen kämpfen wir ja so laut dagegen. Aber die Normalbevölkerung denkt einfach, ach naja, wenn das so schlimm wäre, wie der CCC sagt, dann würde das schon nicht passieren. Weil wir hier in Deutschland, wir haben eine Demokratie bei uns, gibt sowas nicht. Ja, aber das ist einfach, die Leute realisieren es nicht und man muss einfach sagen, also es gibt andere Länder, wo du sowas erleben kannst, zum Beispiel den arabischen Raum, die haben auch weitgehende Internetzenso. Also das ist in der Tat in vielen Ländern der Welt ein echtes Problem, dass das Internet zensiert wird und das ist nicht nur eine theoretische Sache, wo der CCC aus ideologischen Erwägungen gegenkämpft, sondern das ist real.
Und in jedem Land hat halt seine Zerbute. In Deutschland zum Beispiel ist es unsere Vergangenheit. Das wird in Japan ganz anders gehandelt. Da kann ich ganz normal in ein Geschäft gehen und original SS-Uniformen kaufen. Das ist da überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Na ja, versuch mal in Japan Schamhaare zu finden. Schamhaare zu finden. Also das ist ja... Die Gesellschaft in Japan möchte ja gerne zensiert werden. Das ist noch mal so ein kulturelles Problem, was ja auch besteht. Hörst du dir das? Ja, natürlich. Also die meisten Japaner sehen das Internet als Bedrohung. Und dass es eben Dinge gibt, die ihre Kinder dort bedrohen und dass es am besten der Staat in irgendeiner Art und Weise regulieren muss.
Also ein guter Vater sitzt sich neben meinem Kind, wenn es am Computer sitzt.
Genau. Und das ist auch dein Bildungsauftrag nicht nur dem Kind gegenüber, sondern auch dem Rest der Welt gegenüber, dass du das erzählst. A, wie man Zensur umgeht, wenn man sie hat. Und B, dass das Aufpassen auf das eigene Kind der Weg ist, wie man Medienkompetenz vermittelt. Und nicht Zensieren vom Internet.
Solange mein Kind nicht 18 ist, habe ich auf mein Kind aufzupassen.
Genau. Weiter machen.
Ja, ich kann das vielleicht machen. Aber jetzt überleg doch mal. Die meisten Leute, die müssen inzwischen schon zwei Jobs haben. Und das geht nicht mehr mit denen. Also die können das nicht.
Da kann man sich ja eine Art Vierkraft einstellen dann. Ja, Witze ist immer einfach. Tut mir leid.
Da kommen wir wieder zum Punkt, dass 80 Prozent der Leute das vielleicht als Idee ganz gut finden, aber das praktisch gar nicht umsetzen können.
Das ist unser Auftrag, das zu ändern.
Da sind wir wieder bei der Bildung. Und ich fand es auch gerade spannend, das über Japan zu hören, weil ich mich das auch manchmal in Deutschland frage. Vielleicht wollen die Leute das ja einfach, dass das alles so schön sauber und abgekappt ist.
Wir wollen einfach, was du ihnen erzählst. Das nennt sich Perception-Management. Das ist aber auch eine eigene Sendung, oder?
Das ist auch eine eigene Sendung.
Wir haben bestimmt noch ein paar Thesen.
Wir machen noch ein paar Thesen. Wir haben jetzt noch 10 Minuten.
Wir machen einfach ganz schnell. Ganz, ganz schnell. Also die nächste These ist, dass EU-Richtlinien bitte, wenn sie schon erfüllt werden, dann als Schnittmenge erfüllt werden. Also wenn sich 10 Länder treffen, oder wie viele wir jetzt halt sind in der EU, wie viele sind wir, 23? Also wenn sich die EU mal wieder einigt, dass wir eine Cybercrime-Convention brauchen, dann soll bitte am Ende jedes Land die Schnittmenge implementieren und nicht jedes Land irgendwie, wozu sie gerade Bock haben. Bei uns ist das regelmäßig so, dass wir nicht nur alles implementieren, sondern noch darüber hinausgehen. Also unsere Regierung nutzt das dann als Vorwand, um Sachen, die sie vorher innenpolitisch nicht durchgekriegt haben, einfach trotzdem zu machen und lügen uns dann ins Gesicht, das sei notwendig, um die EU-Richtlinien zu erfüllen. Und das möchten wir gar nicht mehr.
Hast du gerade Vorratsdatenspeicher angesagt?
Aber das wäre ein Beispiel. Vielen Dank, dass du das angesprochen hast. So, die nächste These geht um Softwarepatente. Da sind wir nämlich auch dagegen. Und zwar nicht nur, weil wir persönlich in der Branche tätig sind, sondern weil Softwarepatente eben die Basis des Internets betreffen. Die Basis-Technologie im Internet. Und das sind inzwischen nicht nur Router und IP-Pakete, sondern das sind auch Sachen wie Video-Codecs. H264. Kann einer mal gugeln, was es da für Probleme gab mit H264 im Browser und warum Chrome und Google jetzt VP8 macht. Das ist alles eine unglaubliche Grütze mit den Software-Patenten. Wir haben die hier zwar theoretisch nicht, aber es gibt in Amerika welche und da sieht man, was das für Probleme hat, die auch uns hier betreffen. Und das braucht man alles nicht. Die müssen wir uns nicht geben, diese ganzen Probleme. Deswegen sollten wir nicht nur bei uns dafür sorgen, dass es keine Software-Patente gibt, sondern wir sollten die bereits erlassenden Software-Patente vom Europäischen Patentamt allesamt für ungültig erklären und festschreiben, dass es auch nie wieder Software-Patente gibt bei uns.
Wenn es gar keine gibt, wie konnten die denn erlassen werden?
Ja, das ganze Patentamt fragen, das verstehe ich auch nicht. Klingt für mich wie Widerspruch, ist aber so.
Okay, herzlich willkommen in der Patentpolitik.
Genau, da machen wir auch mal... Das Problem des Patentamt ist inzwischen ein sogenannter Profit Center. Die nehmen nämlich Geld pro Patentanmeldung und wenn die anfangen, zu viele Patente zurückzuweisen, haben die Angst, dass dann weniger neue reinkommen. Deswegen nehmen sie lieber mehr Patente, auch wenn die ungültig sind. Und die Firmen spekulieren darauf, dass die irgendwann gültig sind. Und dann müssen sie halt nicht mehr anstehen, um ihre Patente reinzukriegen, sondern die sind halt schon drin.
Wow, noch mal eine eigene Sendung.
Noch mal eine eigene Sendung, genau. So, die nächste These, der geht zum Haftung. Und zwar meinen wir damit erstens die Internetprovider. Also wenn ich meinen Blog irgendwo hoste, dann ist das meine Verantwortung und nicht die von meinem Provider. Und der Provider hat unter gar keinem Umstellen für irgendwelche Inhalte zu haften, die ich da reingestellt habe.
Und wenn du dein Blog hostest, bist du ja noch...
Wenn ich ein Blog hoste, wo auch andere Leute posten können, dann habe ich keine Verantwortung für die Sachen, die andere Leute bei mir reinstellen. Aber es gibt eine Take-down-Notice- und Take-down-Sache. Das ist eigentlich eine ganz, ganz gute Regelung. Wenn ich gegen irgendwas verstoße mit meinem Blog, weil irgendein Typ da was gepostet hat, und ich hab das noch nicht gesehen, oder es war mir nicht klar, dass das eine Verletzung ist, dann sagt man mir Bescheid und ich muss das dann zeitnah löschen. Und wenn ich das nicht tue, dann kann man drüber nachdenken, ob ich belangbar werde. Aber sobald dieses Damoklesschwert der Haftung über einem schwebt, ist das ein großer Hammer, der im Moment dafür sorgt, dass alle möglichen Geschichten einfach verschwinden. Auch der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk löscht gerne mal einfach Nachrichten aus den Archiven oder bei Tagesschau-Streams heißt es dann, aus rechtlichen Gründen darf dieser Teil nicht gesendet werden. Oder wenn Panorama mal wieder einen Beitrag gemacht hat, der übers Ziel hinausgeschossen ist, dann kommt die große Haftungskeule und dann rechnet sich eben NDR aus, naja, es ist jetzt billiger, das erstmal rauszunehmen und später kann man es ja wieder reinstellen. Aber das später wieder reinstellen gibt es halt nicht mehr, wenn wir auf sieben Tage limitieren. Also diese Haftungskeule ist im Moment der große, das große Damoklesschwert, mit der unter anderem die Urheberrechtssachen durchgeführt werden.
Also, aber um zusammenzufassen, es geht doch nicht um Verantwortungslosigkeit, sondern es geht darum, dass jeder nur für sein Zeug verantwortlich ist.
Genau, jeder haftet für das Zeug, was er gemacht hat und nicht für andere Leute Sachen. Denn wenn wir anfangen, den Internet-Providern Haftungen anzudrohen für Inhalte anderer Leute, dann werden sie einfach dafür sorgen, dass Sachen nicht mehr veröffentlicht werden, wenn irgendein Zweifel besteht. Und dann haben wir wieder eine Diktatur, das wollen wir nicht. Deswegen muss das von vorne rein vom Tisch, das ist im Moment eigentlich auch so geregelt. Aber wir möchten gern, dass es so bleibt, deswegen sagen wir das nochmal extra. So, jetzt haben wir eigentlich nur noch zwei Thesen, die uns wirklich wichtig waren. Wir haben nämlich die Rundfunkräte. Und zwar ist da der Punkt, dass der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk eine Quelle ist für Daten. Wir haben auf der einen Seite natürlich die privatwirtschaftlichen Verlage, die uns Zeitungen wie den Spiegel oder Tagespiegel oder was weiß ich publizieren. Da können wir unsere Daten herbeziehen. Oder wir können zum öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk gehen. Und der hat im Moment den Auftrag, uns zu informieren. Und zwar unabhängig. Aber das hilft ja nicht, wenn ich eine Woche im Urlaub bin. Und während der Woche kann ich das nicht abrufen, weil es nämlich einen Filter auf das Land gibt. Und wenn ich zurückkomme, ist es nicht mehr im Archiv. Also wir finden...
Die sieben Tage ist nur ein Tagesaktuelles. Also die Verweildauer, so heißt es so schön, ist ein Jahr.
Ja, das hängt vom Inhalt ab.
Genau, das hängt vom Inhalt ab.
Genau, aber das ist doch scheiße.
Und warum überhaupt auch nur ein Jahr? Also warum wird das überhaupt begrenzt in Zeiten, in denen wir eigentlich speichern können, ohne dass uns der Platz ausgeht?
Das liegt ja nicht daran, dass es gewisse Leute gibt, die sagen, der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk hat im Netz nichts zu suchen. Also jetzt grob zusammengefasst.
Nein, aber das ist doch eine vollkommen unsinnige Argumentation. Ich bezahle doch mit meinen Steuergeldern, dass es diesen öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk gibt. Und ich bin doch heute kein Konsument mehr, der mit seinem Weltempfänger zu Hause sitzt, sondern ich bin jemand, der primär das Internet benutzt. Und das ist doch eigentlich, wenn ich möchte, dass es diesen Rundfunk gibt, den öffentlich-rechtlichen, dann doch im Internet. Alles Weitere können wir von mir drüber reden, ob wir das noch brauchen in Zukunft.
Bis auf Radio, da brauchen wir zumindest am letzten Mittwoch im Monat mindestens einen Sender in Berlin. Aber abgesehen davon, wenn ich dafür bezahle, dass diese Inhalte gemacht werden und dass sie vorliegen, die liegen ja auch digital vor, dann möchte ich bitte, dass mit meinen Geldern auch dafür gesorgt wird, dass die für immer abrufbar sind. Also wenn irgendwie ein Blitz einschlägt und ein Erdbeben das Archiv frisst, okay, da kann man drüber reden. Aber es soll jeder irgendwie vertretbarer Aufwand getrieben werden, damit das im Internet verfügbar ist und bleibt.
Was haltet ihr von der Idee, dass der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk alle seine Inhalte unter eine Creative Commons-Lizenz stellt und damit quasi so eine Art Cloud-basierte Verteilung seiner Inhalte macht?
Das folgt ja aus dem anderen Ding, was wir gesagt haben, Sachen, die mit Steuergeldern finanziert werden. Das ist jetzt keine Steuergelder, aber mit öffentlichen Mitteln.
Wird sie dann bald.
Genau, das ist ja auch bald. Sie sind automatisch allgemein frei. Das finde ich auch nach wie vor.
Das finde ich auch.
Das gilt auch für Rundfunk natürlich. Und die Sachen sollen alle im Internet sein und bleiben. Und dazu gehört eben nicht nur, dass die Daten alle da sein sollen, sondern auch, dass wir uns an den Auftrag erinnern sollen von dem öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk. Und dass das Programm eben nicht wie im Moment von irgendwelchen Rundfunkgeräten überwacht wird, wo irgendwelche Leute drin sitzen, die ich nicht wählen kann, sondern die nach irgendwelchen Kriterien vergeben sind, völlig untransparent und wo im Grunde, also beim ZDF ist ja relativ offensichtlich gewesen, Klientelpolitik betrieben wird. Sondern das soll tatsächlich unabhängig sein. So, das war zu den Rundfunkgeräten. Und die letzte Forderung, die haben wir auch schon fast am Ende, richtig? Was?
Nein.
Eine haben wir noch.
IT-Großprojekte. Also wir hätten gerne, dass IT-Großprojekte tatsächlich mit Sachverstand gemacht werden und nicht als Förderprogramm wie im Moment. Im Moment ist es so, wenn die Regierung irgendwelche IT-Großprojekte macht, wie zum Beispiel Mautbrücken, dass sie dann eben nicht danach gehen, was sinnvoll und umsetzbar ist, sondern dass sie das größtmögliche Projekt sich überlegen, dann irgendwas von Exportschlagerfaseln und nicht danach gehen, ob das A sinnvoll, B bezahlbar und C eine Restwahrscheinlichkeit hat, dass es auch funktionieren kann. Und nicht nur bei IT-Großprojekten, auch bei Gesetzen hätten wir gerne, dass die Regierung vorher mal Experten fragt und dann auch auf die hört.
Es geht ja vor allem ums aufhören. Es wird ja genug nach Experten gefragt. Das haben wir ja auch schon ein paar Mal jetzt gehabt.
Wir werden auch immer wieder gern befragt, übrigens, aber man hört nicht auf uns.
Du wolltest doch die Geschichte zu diesem Punkt erzählen, die ich jetzt wirklich gerne noch hören würde. Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Hackertools, genau. Das war genau so ein Ding. Da sind wir, also der CCC, praktisch als Sachverständiger vorgeladen worden in einen Bundestagsausschuss. Da ging es um das Hackertool-Verbot und ich bin dahin gegangen für den CCC. Und wir wurden mit den Worten begrüßt. Herzlich willkommen, meine Damen und Herren. Vielen Dank, dass Sie noch mal gekommen sind, nachdem wir es schon die letzten drei Male ignoriert haben. Und da dachte ich so, das ist jetzt ein Witz, oder? Aber genau so war es. Da waren zwölf Sachverständige. Alle haben unisono gesagt, dieses Gesetz ist scheiße, macht es nicht, ihr macht euch lächerlich, alle lachen über euch und ihr werdet unsere Industrie kaputt machen. Haben alle gesagt, alle Sachverständigen haben es gesagt. Und die Politiker haben sie angehört und haben dann doch dafür gestimmt.
Gleich danach?
Ja, ziemlich direkt danach, klar. Also das ist ja nur ein Ausschuss, die machen ja nicht das Gesetz. Aber der Ausschuss schreibt dann ein Papier, da steht drin, das ist ein gutes Gesetz, stimmt dafür. Das geht dann an die Fraktionen. Und die stimmen dann halt nach Fraktionen. Das heißt, die Sachverständigen lädt man nur ein, damit ich nachher nicht sagen kann, aus Formgründen ist das Gesetz ungültig, denn da sind keine Sachverständigen befragt worden.
Ach, das gibt es eigentlich in der Verpflichtung aber in Deutschland.
Na klar, sonst würde ich es so nicht machen. Also die fragen Sachverständige und ignorieren das. Und zwar regelmäßig. Das ist kein Einzelfall, sondern das ist tatsächlich so gut wie immer so. Da werden Sachverständige eingeladen und das sind auch tatsächlich Sachverständige. Das wäre ja meine Idee gewesen, wenn ich irgendwie der Mafiaboss wäre, der hier seine Diktatur managen muss, dann hätte ich mir vorgestellt, dass ich da einfach irgendwelche Pfeifen einlade, die halt meine Meinung sind. Aber nein, die laden tatsächlich Sachverständige ein, die alle unisono dagegen sind, und dann machen sie es trotzdem. Und das kann ja mal nicht sein.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob man das jemals umsetzen könnte. Ich glaube es ja direkt nicht. Wir haben jetzt heute über Thesen gesprochen, wo du hast manchmal betont, dass das sozusagen eine persönliche Meinung ist, aber manchmal auch schon, dass mehrere Leute das so sehen. Wird es da noch so eine Art Paper, hätte ich jetzt beinahe gesagt, also irgendwie Internet abrufbar, die Thesen von CCC?
Genau, das ist der Plan, dass wir in naher Zukunft Zeiten haben, gesprochen wir in wahrer Politik. Ein paar Thesen, Politiken, veröffentlichten, klar. Und ja, also das ist erstmal nur ein Entwurf hier. Aber das wird es auch schriftlich geben. Und mit, ja, ihr werdet auch, wenn ihr Kommentare habt, könnt ihr die uns jetzt schon geben natürlich.
Im Blog zur Sendung auf chaosradio.de Da gibt es auch den Podcast imnächst. Ich danke euch fürs Husein. Fefe und Daniel waren heute hier zu Gast, um mal darüber zu sprechen, wie Netzpolitik in Deutschland aussehen sollte, nach Meinung des Chaos Computer Clubs. Nach uns folgen, wie jede Woche um diese Zeit, Smith und Smart und vorher, ich sag übrigens gerne, was die in der Sendung machen und die posten das normalerweise auch meistens, aber diese Woche haben sie es irgendwie total verpeilt. Ich kriege jetzt von draußen gerade Handzeichen. Ja guck doch mal, wir haben es noch eingeschrieben. Jetzt ist zu spät. Jetzt hören wir die Musik, die ich noch ausgesucht habe und die auch an... Ja, nachdem ich nachgefragt habe, oder was? Ja, guck doch mal richtig da.
Also pass auf.
Wir gehen jetzt einfach, überlassen euch diesen komischen Chaoten hier, die nicht wissen, wie das komische Gesicht... Wir gehen jetzt mal schnell. Smart hat mich geradezu verdonnert.